Instacart knows that some people go bananas about getting the perfect, well, banana.
Some want them green.
Some want them ripe.
Some want them ready right when they hit their doorstep.
But with Instacart's preference picker, available at most retailers, you can choose to get your groceries just the way you like.
That means perfectly ripe bananas.
Deli meat sliced just the way you want.
And avocados that aren't still hard as a puck in the third period.
Instacart knows that some people go bananas about getting the perfect, well, banana. Some want them green. Some want them ripe. Some want them ready right when they hit their doorstep. But with Instacart's preference picker, available at most retailers, you can choose to get your groceries just the way you like. That means perfectly ripe bananas. Deli meat sliced just the way you want. And avocados that aren't still hard as a puck in the third period.
So don't cross your fingers and hope for the best.
Download the app and get groceries just how you like with Instacart.
I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
So don't cross your fingers and hope for the best. Download the app and get groceries just how you like with Instacart. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hi.
Hello there.
What's up?
What's up with you?
I don't know. You kind of got that look that, I don't know, is something going on? You have that look. You're like, ew.
No, I'm just excited to be here because we're coming back from a little bit of a vacation.
It's so funny. And so I'm just like excited to be sitting here face to face. You're just happy. And I'm like, what's going on?
No, I know. What if you've been up to? I haven't seen you in two weeks, lady.
Hi. Hello there. What's up? What's up with you? I don't know. You kind of got that look that, I don't know, is something going on? You have that look. You're like, ew. No, I'm just excited to be here because we're coming back from a little bit of a vacation. It's so funny. And so I'm just like excited to be sitting here face to face. You're just happy. And I'm like, what's going on? No, I know. What if you've been up to? I haven't seen you in two weeks, lady.
Oh my gosh. Well, okay, our kids are doing these summer like college programs where you go.
go to a university. They had to apply and they go to a university. Isbel and Jack are doing this?
They live in a dorm for four weeks. They take a course. They get three college credits out of it.
You know, they're going to be seniors in high school next year. But this is like a true like,
hey, here's what college is going to be like a little bit, right? It's a little practice run.
Because you like moved them into the dorm rooms. Like they're getting a whole dorm room thing.
Oh yeah. They each have roommates that they didn't know until they got.
there and signed in. They found out who their roommate was. You know, we had to do that thing where
Oh my gosh. Well, okay, our kids are doing these summer like college programs where you go. go to a university. They had to apply and they go to a university. Isbel and Jack are doing this? They live in a dorm for four weeks. They take a course. They get three college credits out of it. You know, they're going to be seniors in high school next year. But this is like a true like, hey, here's what college is going to be like a little bit, right? It's a little practice run. Because you like moved them into the dorm rooms. Like they're getting a whole dorm room thing. Oh yeah. They each have roommates that they didn't know until they got. there and signed in. They found out who their roommate was. You know, we had to do that thing where
we got bins and we labeled everything and we packed it all up and we got there and the two
different dorms they're in. One of them, the line for the elevator to move in was so long because
everyone showed up with their parents. So Isabel's on the fourth floor. Josh was like,
let's just take the stairs. Lady. What? Yes. We moved her in just walking upstairs all day,
carrying things. And Josh is very fit. I am not as fit. You are fit, but there's a difference
between like, like, you have a type of, like, tennis fitness fitness. Yes. It doesn't translate to,
like, carrying heavy things and climbing. Right. Anyway, so I am sore today, but we got them moved in.
By the time you guys hear this, they will have completed their program. But that's what I've been up to.
we got bins and we labeled everything and we packed it all up and we got there and the two different dorms they're in. One of them, the line for the elevator to move in was so long because everyone showed up with their parents. So Isabel's on the fourth floor. Josh was like, let's just take the stairs. Lady. What? Yes. We moved her in just walking upstairs all day, carrying things. And Josh is very fit. I am not as fit. You are fit, but there's a difference between like, like, you have a type of, like, tennis fitness fitness. Yes. It doesn't translate to, like, carrying heavy things and climbing. Right. Anyway, so I am sore today, but we got them moved in. By the time you guys hear this, they will have completed their program. But that's what I've been up to.
I've been packing up two teenagers and taking them off to this college and getting them moved into a dorm room.
And now they're there.
And like we get calls like Isabel's like, I'm going to do laundry, but they don't take coins anymore.
I'm like, what?
How do you do laundry?
I would save up my coins.
Of course, a Ziploc bag full of coins for the parking meters and the laundry.
I didn't even think about it.
I've been packing up two teenagers and taking them off to this college and getting them moved into a dorm room. And now they're there. And like we get calls like Isabel's like, I'm going to do laundry, but they don't take coins anymore. I'm like, what? How do you do laundry? I would save up my coins. Of course, a Ziploc bag full of coins for the parking meters and the laundry. I didn't even think about it.
It's all an app now.
There's like the laundry app.
Don't get me started.
Do you know how many apps they've had to download?
There's so many apps.
We don't want to look at our phones that much, but like you need an app for everything.
We got a garage door.
And the garage door guy was like, do you want an app on your phone to open and close your garage
It's all an app now. There's like the laundry app. Don't get me started. Do you know how many apps they've had to download? There's so many apps. We don't want to look at our phones that much, but like you need an app for everything. We got a garage door. And the garage door guy was like, do you want an app on your phone to open and close your garage
door?
I said I don't.
You know what I want?
I want a freaking button that I hold on my hand.
Give me a clicker.
He was like, subtle down, lady.
I couldn't believe it.
I triggered you asking you about an app.
door? I said I don't. You know what I want? I want a freaking button that I hold on my hand. Give me a clicker. He was like, subtle down, lady. I couldn't believe it. I triggered you asking you about an app.
But I was like, well, you did.
I know.
Everything's an app now.
Yeah.
Anyway, it's good to see you.
you've been? I've been good. You know, Lee's movie Nimrods comes out very soon. I know. And we are trying to
figure out our red carpet looks because lady, the whole family is walking the red carpet. And we've
never done this before. So number one, I'm just trying to wrap my head around that. Like,
But I was like, well, you did. I know. Everything's an app now. Yeah. Anyway, it's good to see you. you've been? I've been good. You know, Lee's movie Nimrods comes out very soon. I know. And we are trying to figure out our red carpet looks because lady, the whole family is walking the red carpet. And we've never done this before. So number one, I'm just trying to wrap my head around that. Like,
what is that? How do I prepare them for that experience? What's the impact of that experience going to be?
But then also, what are we wearing? Like, are you going to coordinate? These are the questions we're asking.
I don't think so. That feels too complicated.
It feels like a...
It feels like a Christmas card.
Right.
You don't need to be a Christmas card tableau.
what is that? How do I prepare them for that experience? What's the impact of that experience going to be? But then also, what are we wearing? Like, are you going to coordinate? These are the questions we're asking. I don't think so. That feels too complicated. It feels like a... It feels like a Christmas card. Right. Right. You don't need to be a Christmas card tableau.
And I love a coordinating Christmas card.
Don't get me wrong.
Oh, I know.
But maybe for the red carpet, you all have your own looks.
Well, we all have our own ideas.
I know Isabel did a red carpet once and you gave me her dress that she wore.
It's beautiful.
And you were like, one day if Harper ever needs it and she was around this same age.
And I love a coordinating Christmas card. Don't get me wrong. Oh, I know. But maybe for the red carpet, you all have your own looks. Well, we all have our own ideas. I know Isabel did a red carpet once and you gave me her dress that she wore. It's beautiful. And you were like, one day if Harper ever needs it and she was around this same age.
Yes, my friend had produced the movie Mulan.
the live action.
Yeah.
And we went and saw it.
Me and Isbel and Jack,
and Jack wore a suit and Isabel wore a dress.
It was really cute.
We got it at the mall.
Yes, my friend had produced the movie Mulan. the live action. Yeah. And we went and saw it. Me and Isbel and Jack, and Jack wore a suit and Isabel wore a dress. It was really cute. We got it at the mall.
It's really a cute dress.
Oh, it's beautiful.
It's beautiful.
Well, unfortunately, the dress doesn't fit.
I was worried about that because I gave it to you like two years ago,
and I'm like, I don't know if it's going to fit her.
Yeah.
I don't even know where to get clothes for myself for the red carpet.
It's really a cute dress. Oh, it's beautiful. It's beautiful. Well, unfortunately, the dress doesn't fit. I was worried about that because I gave it to you like two years ago, and I'm like, I don't know if it's going to fit her. Yeah. I don't even know where to get clothes for myself for the red carpet.
I know.
I don't know what we're all going to wear.
I hate red carpets.
I know.
I'm excited for the movie.
I will be on the red carpet with you.
Yes, you will.
I don't have an outfit.
I know. I don't know what we're all going to wear. I hate red carpets. I know. I'm excited for the movie. I will be on the red carpet with you. Yes, you will. I don't have an outfit.
No.
We should really be thinking about this because it's happening.
I know.
It's exciting.
The movie comes out August 14th, everybody, in theaters worldwide.
Worldwide.
Global.
Global release.
No. We should really be thinking about this because it's happening. I know. It's exciting. The movie comes out August 14th, everybody, in theaters worldwide. Worldwide. Global. Global release.
Oh, but also, lady, they are doing special early screenings of Nimrods in select theaters.
It's happening on Tuesday, August 11th.
So everyone, check the listings at your local theaters and see if they have one of the early
screenings, my folks, my sister, and some of my high school friends, they all got tickets to
one of the early screenings in St. Louis.
Aw.
I know.
I'm so excited for them to see it.
Oh, but also, lady, they are doing special early screenings of Nimrods in select theaters. It's happening on Tuesday, August 11th. So everyone, check the listings at your local theaters and see if they have one of the early screenings, my folks, my sister, and some of my high school friends, they all got tickets to one of the early screenings in St. Louis. Aw. I know. I'm so excited for them to see it.
Well, it's such a fun movie to see with a group of people in the theater.
Yes, in the theater, because of course there's all the great music in it, too.
You want to hear that and see that on the big screen.
So everyone, please grab your friends and check out Nimrods.
That's so fun.
We're going to be in a movie, lady.
Together.
Well, it's such a fun movie to see with a group of people in the theater. Yes, in the theater, because of course there's all the great music in it, too. You want to hear that and see that on the big screen. So everyone, please grab your friends and check out Nimrods. That's so fun. We're going to be in a movie, lady. Together. Together.
In the theaters.
exciting. It's so exciting. We've been on a TV show together. Yep. We have written a book together. We have done a podcast together. We have never been in a movie together. Oh, my gosh. The last thing would be like if we did a piece of theater together. Oh, that would be so cool. I don't want the lead. That's too much pressure. I want to tell you right now. You can be the lead. I would just like to be someone that makes a lot of entrances. I think those are so fun. Like, I love it when I go see a play.
The person I want to be is like, like, let's say you're at a restaurant.
And it's a waitress that comes in and out.
And she has a little business and she says something that she's back out.
And then she's back in with some more, you know, something else she's caring and saying, I want to be that person.
You know, when we were in New York, I saw this play called The Ballasters.
Oh my gosh, lady.
In the theaters. exciting. It's so exciting. We've been on a TV show together. Yep. We have written a book together. We have done a podcast together. We have never been in a movie together. Oh, my gosh. The last thing would be like if we did a piece of theater together. Oh, that would be so cool. I don't want the lead. That's too much pressure. I want to tell you right now. You can be the lead. I would just like to be someone that makes a lot of entrances. I think those are so fun. Like, I love it when I go see a play. The person I want to be is like, like, let's say you're at a restaurant. And it's a waitress that comes in and out. And she has a little business and she says something that she's back out. And then she's back in with some more, you know, something else she's caring and saying, I want to be that person. You know, when we were in New York, I saw this play called The Ballasters. Oh my gosh, lady.
It's so funny.
It's about like a neighborhood association meeting.
It happens in like a living room.
And it's a series of meetings.
And it's all about whether or not they should put a stop sign.
on a road or not.
I would love that.
It does not disappoint, and it's so good, and it's filled with all these amazing characters,
It's so funny. It's about like a neighborhood association meeting. It happens in like a living room. And it's a series of meetings. And it's all about whether or not they should put a stop sign. on a road or not. I would love that. It does not disappoint, and it's so good, and it's filled with all these amazing characters,
and there are, like, two characters that, like, in another 15 years, you would be so perfect
as great entrances, just, like, drop mic comedic timing.
You'd love it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll put it on my list.
Okay.
And there's, like, two older women in this, and we could pick which one we each want
and there are, like, two characters that, like, in another 15 years, you would be so perfect as great entrances, just, like, drop mic comedic timing. You'd love it. Okay. Yeah. I'll put it on my list. Okay. And there's, like, two older women in this, and we could pick which one we each want
to be, and that we can be in a play together.
when they revive the balusters.
Okay.
There it is.
We figured it out.
You guys, we had a lot of banter here because we haven't seen each other, but we have a
fantastic episode today.
to be, and that we can be in a play together. when they revive the balusters. Okay. Okay. There it is. We figured it out. You guys, we had a lot of banter here because we haven't seen each other, but we have a fantastic episode today.
Yes.
We had the most amazing conversation with writer, producer, director, and author, Mike Scher.
He was in studio with us, and we cannot wait for you to hear this interview.
It's so fun.
He's so smart.
It's great.
We talk a lot about the office.
So you know, you guys, last time when Mike was here, it was in 2022, episode 107 of Office Ladies.
Yes. We had the most amazing conversation with writer, producer, director, and author, Mike Scher. He was in studio with us, and we cannot wait for you to hear this interview. It's so fun. He's so smart. It's great. We talk a lot about the office. So you know, you guys, last time when Mike was here, it was in 2022, episode 107 of Office Ladies.
It's a great listen if you haven't heard it.
He zoomed into the studio.
We didn't actually have him in person that time.
So it was really fun to be sitting across the table from him today.
And in that first interview, we talked with him about how he got his job on the office.
We talk a lot about him playing the character, Moes.
Yes.
And what that was like.
It's a great listen if you haven't heard it. He zoomed into the studio. We didn't actually have him in person that time. So it was really fun to be sitting across the table from him today. And in that first interview, we talked with him about how he got his job on the office. We talk a lot about him playing the character, Moes. Yes. And what that was like.
And also what he learned in the writer's room and what he learned from Greg Daniels about
writing comedy. That is a great interview. I didn't think we could top that with him. And then today,
we dive into his episodes that he wrote. Yes, we asked him if we could just sort of take him through
some of the episodes that he wrote and his memory for detail and lines and specificity and just how a
story was crafted or how a joke was crafted. Oh my gosh. And he was so generous with his time.
And then we had an amazing conversation about his book that just came out.
It's called Big Fan.
He wrote it with his friend Joe Posnansky, who is a sports writer.
And also what he learned in the writer's room and what he learned from Greg Daniels about writing comedy. That is a great interview. I didn't think we could top that with him. And then today, we dive into his episodes that he wrote. Yes, we asked him if we could just sort of take him through some of the episodes that he wrote and his memory for detail and lines and specificity and just how a story was crafted or how a joke was crafted. Oh my gosh. And he was so generous with his time. And then we had an amazing conversation about his book that just came out. It's called Big Fan. He wrote it with his friend Joe Posnansky, who is a sports writer.
And they just traveled around the world trying to discover what makes you a fan of something like sports, music, TV.
Yes.
And what that phenomenon of fandom is to us as human beings.
It's a great conversation.
Yes. And in the Mike sure way that he is, he just has a way of understanding people and what makes us human.
He's a great observer. Yes. Yes. And so we just can't wait for you to hear it.
Well, why don't we take a break? We will save our chit chats and around the town for our next episode because we thought we were going to chat with Mike for about 25, 30 minutes. You guys, we talked for an hour, but it's so good. And you're going to love it.
We want you to hear it all.
And they just traveled around the world trying to discover what makes you a fan of something like sports, music, TV. Yes. And what that phenomenon of fandom is to us as human beings. It's a great conversation. Yes. And in the Mike sure way that he is, he just has a way of understanding people and what makes us human. He's a great observer. Yes. Yes. And so we just can't wait for you to hear it. Well, why don't we take a break? We will save our chit chats and around the town for our next episode because we thought we were going to chat with Mike for about 25, 30 minutes. You guys, we talked for an hour, but it's so good. And you're going to love it. We want you to hear it all.
So we'll take a break and we'll be right back with Mike Scher.
Hello.
Hi, Mike.
I am so happy to see both of you.
How have you been?
How is everything?
We're good.
So we'll take a break and we'll be right back with Mike Scher. Hello. Hello. Hi, Mike. I am so happy to see both of you. How have you been? How is everything? We're good.
Yeah?
How are you?
I'm great.
It's so great to see you.
You look literally the same.
I was thinking the same thing about you.
I don't know if you're supposed to say that to people.
No, look, we all are aging exactly the same rate.
Yeah? How are you? I'm great. It's so great to see you. You look literally the same. I was thinking the same thing about you. I don't know if you're supposed to say that to people. No, look, we all are aging exactly the same rate.
One day per day.
And when I see people from the office, I think like, yeah, that's how the person looks.
Like if you've known the person continuously, they just stay the same in your brain.
But you know what's crazy?
So I was cleaning my sag award the other day.
You were what?
First of all, incredible way to start a sentence.
I know, right?
One day per day. And when I see people from the office, I think like, yeah, that's how the person looks. Like if you've known the person continuously, they just stay the same in your brain. But you know what's crazy? So I was cleaning my sag award the other day. You were what? First of all, incredible way to start a sentence. I know, right?
I've never cleaned fine.
I was dusting.
You've never cleaned your sag award?
I had an idiot.
Did you not consult the manual for proper maintenance?
I haven't.
And also it has a tush.
So, you know.
I've never cleaned fine. I was dusting. You've never cleaned your sag award? I had an idiot. Did you not consult the manual for proper maintenance? I haven't. And also it has a tush. So, you know.
It does.
It has, anyway.
Is it like taking care of an infant a little bit?
I don't know.
I haven't thought about it.
Go on, Jenna.
I was moving things on my bookshelf in my office.
And, you know, so I was cleaning my SAG Award.
It does. It has, anyway. Is it like taking care of an infant a little bit? I don't know. I haven't thought about it. Go on, Jenna. I was moving things on my bookshelf in my office. And, you know, so I was cleaning my SAG Award.
And I looked at the date on it.
And it said 2006.
And I was like, wait.
Whoa.
That was 20 years ago?
20 years ago.
What?
Yeah.
And I looked at the date on it. And it said 2006. And I was like, wait. Whoa. That was 20 years ago? 20 years ago. What? Yeah.
I know.
We're passing all those milestones now where you see things on social media that's like the 25th anniversary of something.
And it's hard to believe.
But yeah.
I mark this every June 1st.
because I moved to LA on June 1st, 2004, to start working on the show.
And so every June 1st, I'm like, oh, wait, how many years has it been that I've lived here?
And now it's 22 years that I've been here.
I know. We're passing all those milestones now where you see things on social media that's like the 25th anniversary of something. And it's hard to believe. But yeah. I mark this every June 1st. because I moved to LA on June 1st, 2004, to start working on the show. And so every June 1st, I'm like, oh, wait, how many years has it been that I've lived here? And now it's 22 years that I've been here.
And we started working on the show, I think, like, right after July 4th weekend, maybe, the writers met for the first time.
And that is inconceivable to me.
I mean, it feels like both forever ago and also yesterday.
Yeah.
Well, listen, the last time you came on the show, we talked a lot about, like, how you got your job on the show.
and how you became Mo's and all those things.
But we didn't get a chance to dig into some of the specific episodes that you wrote.
Great, let's do it.
And we started working on the show, I think, like, right after July 4th weekend, maybe, the writers met for the first time. And that is inconceivable to me. I mean, it feels like both forever ago and also yesterday. Yeah. Well, listen, the last time you came on the show, we talked a lot about, like, how you got your job on the show. and how you became Mo's and all those things. But we didn't get a chance to dig into some of the specific episodes that you wrote. Great, let's do it.
So we were thinking maybe we could talk about a few.
So speaking of the early days, the Alliance, it's season one of the office,
and you guys are trying to establish what is the American version of this?
Right.
How do we make it our own thing?
Can you take me back to that time?
Yeah.
So that first season, it was just me, Mindy, and BJ,
So we were thinking maybe we could talk about a few. So speaking of the early days, the Alliance, it's season one of the office, and you guys are trying to establish what is the American version of this? Right. How do we make it our own thing? Can you take me back to that time? Yeah. So that first season, it was just me, Mindy, and BJ,
the only full-time writers. And then the late Lester Lewis, RIP, was a consultant, and Larry Wilmore
was a consultant, and Paul Lieberstein was a consultant. And it was a very small crew. And in classic
Greg Daniels fashion, we came up with 270 episode ideas to make five episodes. And I want to say
the alliance, one of the things that is going on in the first season of the British office is the
threat of downsizing and the threat of consolidation and a branch closing and that sort of stuff.
It sort of runs in the background. And Greg wanted to maintain that because it was and is such a
part of like corporate life that you're always like, is someone going to buy our company and
are we all going to lose our jobs? And so he wanted that theme to run through the season in a low grade
the only full-time writers. And then the late Lester Lewis, RIP, was a consultant, and Larry Wilmore was a consultant, and Paul Lieberstein was a consultant. And it was a very small crew. And in classic Greg Daniels fashion, we came up with 270 episode ideas to make five episodes. And I want to say the alliance, one of the things that is going on in the first season of the British office is the threat of downsizing and the threat of consolidation and a branch closing and that sort of stuff. It sort of runs in the background. And Greg wanted to maintain that because it was and is such a part of like corporate life that you're always like, is someone going to buy our company and are we all going to lose our jobs? And so he wanted that theme to run through the season in a low grade
way. And the simple nugget of the idea was that in this kind of vague threat of something bad
happening in the office that because Survivor was such a big deal at the time.
Like, people forget, like Survivor had debuted, I think, in the year 2000 or something.
And around 2004, it was like the biggest deal.
It still is a huge deal, but it was the biggest deal.
And I want to say it was BJ, my memory might be failing me, who pitched the idea of just
Dwight asking Jim to form an alliance with him, Survivor style.
And we like that idea.
way. And the simple nugget of the idea was that in this kind of vague threat of something bad happening in the office that because Survivor was such a big deal at the time. Like, people forget, like Survivor had debuted, I think, in the year 2000 or something. And around 2004, it was like the biggest deal. It still is a huge deal, but it was the biggest deal. And I want to say it was BJ, my memory might be failing me, who pitched the idea of just Dwight asking Jim to form an alliance with him, Survivor style. And we like that idea.
Obviously, like Jim and Dwight, famous antagonist, but the breakthrough was.
that someone pitched, I'd like to take credit for it, but I don't know if I can, that Jim's
response was absolutely I do.
Like instantly.
I was going to ask you about that because that's like such a famous couplet that comes back
later.
It was absolutely I do.
And then the talking head that comes after it is anytime Dwight asked me to do anything,
Obviously, like Jim and Dwight, famous antagonist, but the breakthrough was. that someone pitched, I'd like to take credit for it, but I don't know if I can, that Jim's response was absolutely I do. Like instantly. I was going to ask you about that because that's like such a famous couplet that comes back later. It was absolutely I do. And then the talking head that comes after it is anytime Dwight asked me to do anything,
my response is absolutely, you know, because Jim's sole goal in life in that moment is to like enjoy
this mundane business.
environment in any way he possibly can.
Just escape the boredom.
And it's one of the great lessons of writing that I've learned a hundred thousand times,
which it's a classic improv thing, right?
It's like yes and it.
my response is absolutely, you know, because Jim's sole goal in life in that moment is to like enjoy this mundane business. environment in any way he possibly can. Just escape the boredom. Just escape the boredom. And it's one of the great lessons of writing that I've learned a hundred thousand times, which it's a classic improv thing, right? It's like yes and it.
Like just say yes.
If you say no, the story ends.
If you say yes, you get a story.
So as soon as we came up with the idea that Dwight makes an absurd request of Jim
and Jim's immediate response is yes, then, okay, we're off and running.
So that was the like simple nugget of the story.
And then it became like, how does Jim enjoy like torturing Dwight and enjoying his life in this boring day and sharing it with Pam, of course.
My favorite scene that came out of it is the one that's sort of a spy scene from up top looking down at them in the parking lot.
Like just say yes. If you say no, the story ends. If you say yes, you get a story. So as soon as we came up with the idea that Dwight makes an absurd request of Jim and Jim's immediate response is yes, then, okay, we're off and running. So that was the like simple nugget of the story. And then it became like, how does Jim enjoy like torturing Dwight and enjoying his life in this boring day and sharing it with Pam, of course. My favorite scene that came out of it is the one that's sort of a spy scene from up top looking down at them in the parking lot.
And they're standing outside and it was, as it always was in the valley, 111 degrees.
But it was supposed to be like November in Scranton.
And so the two of them just are grabbing their arms in the classic pose of person trying to warm.
Which we would then do 50 more times over the course of the first couple seasons.
And having that like private kind of survivor-like conversation about like, you know, how to play things and what they've learned and all that stuff.
So that was it.
It was what made that show so special to me was like, that's what you needed for a story.
You didn't need a gigantic huge plot.
And they're standing outside and it was, as it always was in the valley, 111 degrees. But it was supposed to be like November in Scranton. And so the two of them just are grabbing their arms in the classic pose of person trying to warm. Which we would then do 50 more times over the course of the first couple seasons. And having that like private kind of survivor-like conversation about like, you know, how to play things and what they've learned and all that stuff. So that was it. It was what made that show so special to me was like, that's what you needed for a story. You didn't need a gigantic huge plot.
You needed one of the ridiculous characters to make.
a request of a sane character and have the same character decide to go along with it for the
day. And that was it. That's a really great way to look at the office now. Like the next time I
watch an episode and be like, okay, who's the ridiculous character asking the same character
to do something? Yeah. And it's usually Michael is the ridiculous one asking Pam or Jim or someone
to do something. Go to Hooters or whatever it was. It was either a sane person doing something
sane and watching the lunatics respond or vice versa, like a lunatic doing something lunatic,
and then the same person's responding.
You needed one of the ridiculous characters to make. a request of a sane character and have the same character decide to go along with it for the day. And that was it. That's a really great way to look at the office now. Like the next time I watch an episode and be like, okay, who's the ridiculous character asking the same character to do something? Yeah. And it's usually Michael is the ridiculous one asking Pam or Jim or someone to do something. Go to Hooters or whatever it was. It was either a sane person doing something sane and watching the lunatics respond or vice versa, like a lunatic doing something lunatic, and then the same person's responding.
You also wrote Valentine's Day.
Yeah.
And this puts the character of Michael Scott in New York City.
Yes.
There are so many funny moments.
What was it like to do that?
Like you're from the East Coast.
And so seeing New York City through Michael Scott's eyes.
You also wrote Valentine's Day. Yeah. And this puts the character of Michael Scott in New York City. Yes. There are so many funny moments. What was it like to do that? Like you're from the East Coast. And so seeing New York City through Michael Scott's eyes.
So that was season two.
Season two.
And it was the beginning of Greg wanting to expand the world of the show occasionally, rarely,
but saying like we can break out a little bit of the rule we had stuck to,
which is every episode happens in one day and every episode happens inside the walls of the office
or on the grounds of Dunder Mifflin.
So we had this idea that he would go to New York.
There were two really important things that I think came out of that episode.
So that was season two. Season two. And it was the beginning of Greg wanting to expand the world of the show occasionally, rarely, but saying like we can break out a little bit of the rule we had stuck to, which is every episode happens in one day and every episode happens inside the walls of the office or on the grounds of Dunder Mifflin. So we had this idea that he would go to New York. There were two really important things that I think came out of that episode.
The first was like, let's take a skeleton crew to the city.
walk around with Steve Correll and just do a bunch of jokes.
In the room, I remember we called it Michael Scott's New York.
That's how he thought of it was like, because his whole thing is I'm an expert on everything.
Yes.
And so we thought it would be really fun to put him in Manhattan, a place where like you've got to, you know,
spend a lot of time in Manhattan to be an expert on it and he is not.
So the joke I wrote that's probably the most famous joke of that episode is the one
The first was like, let's take a skeleton crew to the city. walk around with Steve Correll and just do a bunch of jokes. In the room, I remember we called it Michael Scott's New York. That's how he thought of it was like, because his whole thing is I'm an expert on everything. Yes. And so we thought it would be really fun to put him in Manhattan, a place where like you've got to, you know, spend a lot of time in Manhattan to be an expert on it and he is not. So the joke I wrote that's probably the most famous joke of that episode is the one
where he talks about taking the camera crew to his favorite pizza place.
and it's a Sparrow.
It's the one that comes back to me the most still to this day.
I mean, people post online pictures of themselves in front of Sparrow.
In Manhattan.
Yeah, and saying, you know.
Yeah, got to get a New York slice.
Yeah.
where he talks about taking the camera crew to his favorite pizza place. and it's a Sparrow. It's the one that comes back to me the most still to this day. I mean, people post online pictures of themselves in front of Sparrow. In Manhattan. Yeah, and saying, you know. Yeah, got to get a New York slice. Yeah.
That episode is largely about him and Jan.
Yes.
And him believing that he has a relationship with Jan that he does not actually have.
But this was the other really important thing about that episode from a like a world building point of view was a question that had.
a question that had been asked many times of the show by critics and fans and all sorts of people was,
how did this dummy get this job?
How did Michael Scott get this job?
And Greg had thought it out very carefully.
That episode is largely about him and Jan. Yes. And him believing that he has a relationship with Jan that he does not actually have. But this was the other really important thing about that episode from a like a world building point of view was a question that had. a question that had been asked many times of the show by critics and fans and all sorts of people was, how did this dummy get this job? How did Michael Scott get this job? And Greg had thought it out very carefully.
It was a living example of what's called in corporate structure, the Peter Principle, right?
Yes, we know the Peter Principle.
We've discussed, right?
People who do a good job at their job are then promoted to a position in which their skills have run out and are no longer out.
They're not qualified for it.
Yeah.
But it was still a question of like, okay, even given that, this guy has done a lot of ridiculous stuff.
So how do we justify it?
It was a living example of what's called in corporate structure, the Peter Principle, right? Yes, we know the Peter Principle. We've discussed, right? People who do a good job at their job are then promoted to a position in which their skills have run out and are no longer out. They're not qualified for it. Yeah. But it was still a question of like, okay, even given that, this guy has done a lot of ridiculous stuff. So how do we justify it?
So the whole point of this episode was we were like, we're going to see four guys, including Michael,
who have Michael's job at different branches.
Two of them are going to be demonstrably more competent than him, and one of them is going to be less competent.
And like, we are going to absolutely show that there are people who have his job who are dumber than he is.
And that was that character who just was like, I thought this was more of like a meet and greet kind of a deal.
He's very funny too.
Yeah, he's very funny.
Craig Anton, I think, is his name.
So the whole point of this episode was we were like, we're going to see four guys, including Michael, who have Michael's job at different branches. Two of them are going to be demonstrably more competent than him, and one of them is going to be less competent. And like, we are going to absolutely show that there are people who have his job who are dumber than he is. And that was that character who just was like, I thought this was more of like a meet and greet kind of a deal. He's very funny too. Yeah, he's very funny. Craig Anton, I think, is his name.
And so Michael does something kind of important too in that episode, which is he has made a ridiculous video.
The CFO, David Wallace, has asked him to make a presentation about his branch, numbers, facts, revenue streams, stuff like that.
And instead, in classic Michael Scott fashion, he decides to make a presentation.
make a video that's like a heart string tugging kind of like these people matter to me.
And he presents that video and David Wallace's reaction is like, wow, but also do you have the
facts I asked for? And the key thing is that he does. That was like a big deal. He passes out these
like really nice like spiral bound. Yes. And it was a demonstration that like even though he's an
absurd person, he's not incompetent. He knows what he has to do. And he also, he was hoping that David
And so Michael does something kind of important too in that episode, which is he has made a ridiculous video. The CFO, David Wallace, has asked him to make a presentation about his branch, numbers, facts, revenue streams, stuff like that. And instead, in classic Michael Scott fashion, he decides to make a presentation. make a video that's like a heart string tugging kind of like these people matter to me. And he presents that video and David Wallace's reaction is like, wow, but also do you have the facts I asked for? And the key thing is that he does. That was like a big deal. He passes out these like really nice like spiral bound. Yes. And it was a demonstration that like even though he's an absurd person, he's not incompetent. He knows what he has to do. And he also, he was hoping that David
Wallace would like start crying because he was so moved by his video that he would see what Michael
sees in the incredible people of Dan Dundermiff and Scranton. So that was the whole purpose of that
besides obviously advancing the Michael Jan relationship was like she gives him a kiss at the end.
She does indeed. She's like surprised by his maneuver that he like owns up to the relationship and
takes the fall for it and protects her. And she's so, you know, sort of like pleased with how he
handle it that she ends up giving him what he hoped he was going to get, which was like a romantic
Valentine's Day New York moment. There's another very important thing that came out of that episode
for me and for America. When we auditioned people for that role that Craig Anton did,
Wallace would like start crying because he was so moved by his video that he would see what Michael sees in the incredible people of Dan Dundermiff and Scranton. So that was the whole purpose of that besides obviously advancing the Michael Jan relationship was like she gives him a kiss at the end. She does indeed. She's like surprised by his maneuver that he like owns up to the relationship and takes the fall for it and protects her. And she's so, you know, sort of like pleased with how he handle it that she ends up giving him what he hoped he was going to get, which was like a romantic Valentine's Day New York moment. There's another very important thing that came out of that episode for me and for America. When we auditioned people for that role that Craig Anton did,
and was very funny. And one of the people we saw was Nick Offerman. Oh. And he auditioned for it.
And we were like, that guy's really funny. But then it immediately came to us before we could, I think,
even offer him the part, maybe, that he had a conflict. And the conflict was he was shooting an episode
of Will and Grace at the same time, because he is famously married to Megan Mullalley. So I wrote the name
Nick Offerman on a post-it note and stuck it to my computer as a reminder to me that like this guy
had audition was really funny. And then three years later, when Greg and I were developing Parks and
Rec, I was like, oh, that guy. That guy's really funny. And he came in and read for,
a bunch of parts and ended up playing Ron Swanson. And when the show ended, I saved the post-it note.
and was very funny. And one of the people we saw was Nick Offerman. Oh. And he auditioned for it. And we were like, that guy's really funny. But then it immediately came to us before we could, I think, even offer him the part, maybe, that he had a conflict. And the conflict was he was shooting an episode of Will and Grace at the same time, because he is famously married to Megan Mullalley. So I wrote the name Nick Offerman on a post-it note and stuck it to my computer as a reminder to me that like this guy had audition was really funny. And then three years later, when Greg and I were developing Parks and Rec, I was like, oh, that guy. That guy's really funny. And he came in and read for, a bunch of parts and ended up playing Ron Swanson. And when the show ended, I saved the post-it note.
Nice. And I had it framed. And it had, in the intervening time, it had fallen off my computer and been
stepped on. So there was like a footprint on it. And someone, some random phone number was also written on it or
whatever. But I saved it and like put it in a frame and gave it to Neck as a present at the end of the show.
But that was where I was where I first saw him. Oh, I'm so glad you told that story for any like aspiring
artists out there who have gone to an audition and then they don't get the part. But like,
you might be on a Post-it note on someone's computer. Like, that might grow into something in
three years. Yeah. It was wonderful the way it all worked out. And it taught us a really important
lesson, which was, and I think this started at the office. If it didn't, it definitely started
Nice. And I had it framed. And it had, in the intervening time, it had fallen off my computer and been stepped on. So there was like a footprint on it. And someone, some random phone number was also written on it or whatever. But I saved it and like put it in a frame and gave it to Neck as a present at the end of the show. But that was where I was where I first saw him. Oh, I'm so glad you told that story for any like aspiring artists out there who have gone to an audition and then they don't get the part. But like, you might be on a Post-it note on someone's computer. Like, that might grow into something in three years. Yeah. It was wonderful the way it all worked out. And it taught us a really important lesson, which was, and I think this started at the office. If it didn't, it definitely started
at Parks and Rec or we took it to Parks and Rec. We used to have a folder on our computer
that called Good for Something. And it would be like we would audition people for roles.
And then if we didn't cast them but we liked them,
we would just take their audition and throw it into that folder.
And then in a future episode, if it was like,
oh, who can play this part,
we would go through that folder and look at all those auditions.
And we go, oh, that lady was funny.
at Parks and Rec or we took it to Parks and Rec. We used to have a folder on our computer that called Good for Something. And it would be like we would audition people for roles. And then if we didn't cast them but we liked them, we would just take their audition and throw it into that folder. And then in a future episode, if it was like, oh, who can play this part, we would go through that folder and look at all those auditions. And we go, oh, that lady was funny.
We'll get her to do it.
And people would constantly on Parks and Rec show up and be like,
I didn't audition for this.
Like, how did this happen?
And we were like, well, we audition for that thing a year ago
and we found you and, you know, saved,
we liked your audition and saved you.
And most of the actors always had that same reaction.
We'll get her to do it. And people would constantly on Parks and Rec show up and be like, I didn't audition for this. Like, how did this happen? And we were like, well, we audition for that thing a year ago and we found you and, you know, saved, we liked your audition and saved you. And most of the actors always had that same reaction.
which was like, thank you so much.
Yes.
But for me, it was like, well, why wouldn't you do that?
It's like, you like an actor.
They did a good job.
Like, actors don't grow on trees.
Like, save them and use them in something, you know.
Two things.
which was like, thank you so much. Yes. But for me, it was like, well, why wouldn't you do that? It's like, you like an actor. They did a good job. Like, actors don't grow on trees. Like, save them and use them in something, you know. Two things.
One, I think it's very Michael Scott of you that you stuck it on your computer.
It is very old-timey.
I usually, I did tidy up, but I normally have Post-it notes.
And I open my laptop in there here because I don't want to, like, forget.
But then also you said, you know, actors don't grow on trees.
which made me think of branch closing because I watched it this morning.
Did you really?
Oh, my gosh.
One, I think it's very Michael Scott of you that you stuck it on your computer. It is very old-timey. I usually, I did tidy up, but I normally have Post-it notes. And I open my laptop in there here because I don't want to, like, forget. But then also you said, you know, actors don't grow on trees. which made me think of branch closing because I watched it this morning. Did you really? Oh, my gosh.
Yes.
It's always been one of my favorite episodes.
And I was like,
I haven't watched it in a bit since we like first broke it down.
But did you write Stanley doesn't grow on trees?
I believe I did.
Yeah.
Because you just said it.
Yes. It's always been one of my favorite episodes. And I was like, I haven't watched it in a bit since we like first broke it down. But did you write Stanley doesn't grow on trees? I believe I did. Yeah. Because you just said it.
So it might be just deep within you.
Show me that farm where, yeah.
Yeah, we're Stanleys and Phyllis's.
Stanley's and Phyllis's.
It's such a good episode.
It like made my morning.
I watched it with a cup of tea.
I remember thinking like that's season three.
So it might be just deep within you. Show me that farm where, yeah. Yeah, we're Stanleys and Phyllis's. Stanley's and Phyllis's. It's such a good episode. It like made my morning. I watched it with a cup of tea. I remember thinking like that's season three.
Yes, it's season three.
And I remember thinking, I remember watching that episode,
watching Steve specifically in that episode and thinking like this is an actor at the height of his powers.
Like it's a great showcase for him for a couple of reasons.
One is the very first scene is Jan coming in and saying this branch is closing.
And he just is usually on the show like there's a little bit of a ramp in, you know,
like starts with some slice of life
and then Michael has some dumb thing
Yes, it's season three. And I remember thinking, I remember watching that episode, watching Steve specifically in that episode and thinking like this is an actor at the height of his powers. Like it's a great showcase for him for a couple of reasons. One is the very first scene is Jan coming in and saying this branch is closing. And he just is usually on the show like there's a little bit of a ramp in, you know, like starts with some slice of life and then Michael has some dumb thing
and then whatever eventually
like a couple minutes in
the premise has sort of sprung.
That episode, Jan walks in
and he's like going,
Jan Levinson Goal, blah, blah, blah.
And then she just goes...
Like Levinson in the morning.
and then whatever eventually like a couple minutes in the premise has sort of sprung. That episode, Jan walks in and he's like going, Jan Levinson Goal, blah, blah, blah. And then she just goes... Like Levinson in the morning.
Just call me Levinson in the morning.
And then she's like,
I'm here to tell you the branch is closing.
And so 30 seconds in,
he gets the worst news of his life.
And that monologue,
that talking head he gives of like
show me that farm is so good.
Just call me Levinson in the morning. And then she's like, I'm here to tell you the branch is closing. And so 30 seconds in, he gets the worst news of his life. And that monologue, that talking head he gives of like show me that farm is so good.
And it's like he has so deeply internalized
the degree to which this office is his entire life.
It's like an incredible performance.
And I remember that was the year,
not to divert the conversation too much
into something that doesn't really matter,
but that was the year that everyone was like,
Steve Corell is going to win the Emmy
And it's like he has so deeply internalized the degree to which this office is his entire life. It's like an incredible performance. And I remember that was the year, not to divert the conversation too much into something that doesn't really matter, but that was the year that everyone was like, Steve Corell is going to win the Emmy
for best actor and a comedy.
It is a foregone conclusion.
In fact, it was such a foregone conclusion
that that year they had,
had Stephen Colbert and John Stewart present the category because it was going to be a daily show
correspondence reunion on stage and they were going to give it to their friend Steve Correll.
And then I believe Ricky Jervais ended up winning for the show extras, which was a BBC show
that HBO had just bought and like thrown on the air. And he wasn't even there. It was one of
for best actor and a comedy. It is a foregone conclusion. In fact, it was such a foregone conclusion that that year they had, had Stephen Colbert and John Stewart present the category because it was going to be a daily show correspondence reunion on stage and they were going to give it to their friend Steve Correll. And then I believe Ricky Jervais ended up winning for the show extras, which was a BBC show that HBO had just bought and like thrown on the air. And he wasn't even there. It was one of
those deals where they showed a black and white photo of him on the screen. And they were like,
Ricky Jervais isn't here. So instead, we're going to give this to our friend Steve
Karel, and then Steve jumped up and ran on stage and, like, bowed and everyone cheered.
But I remember thinking of all of the robberies that occurred from folks who worked on the office over
the years, that season three best actor in a comedy was number one on my list because he was the
funniest person in America, and he was the best actor on a comedy in America by a wide margin.
And I always think of that performance in that episode is Exhibit A in that argument.
Yeah, he's fantastic in it.
those deals where they showed a black and white photo of him on the screen. And they were like, Ricky Jervais isn't here. So instead, we're going to give this to our friend Steve Karel, and then Steve jumped up and ran on stage and, like, bowed and everyone cheered. But I remember thinking of all of the robberies that occurred from folks who worked on the office over the years, that season three best actor in a comedy was number one on my list because he was the funniest person in America, and he was the best actor on a comedy in America by a wide margin. And I always think of that performance in that episode is Exhibit A in that argument. Yeah, he's fantastic in it.
Yeah.
And he never won an Emmy for the role of it.
Michael Scott. He never did. Never did. When I speak to acting classes, I remind them of that fact that you can do the best work.
You can be the very, very best of what you do. Yeah. I know. At this point, it's like you can make a better cast and show out of the folks who have never won than the folks who have won, I dare say. And he's the lead.
Yeah, they had a camera on us. I've told this story before. We were in a row together. It was like Jenna and John and me.
in the same row and Steve was in front of us.
And, you know, when they're announcing the nominees, the camera guys just run right up.
Right.
Yeah. And he never won an Emmy for the role of it. Michael Scott. He never did. Never did. When I speak to acting classes, I remind them of that fact that you can do the best work. You can be the very, very best of what you do. Yeah. I know. At this point, it's like you can make a better cast and show out of the folks who have never won than the folks who have won, I dare say. And he's the lead. Yeah, they had a camera on us. I've told this story before. We were in a row together. It was like Jenna and John and me. in the same row and Steve was in front of us. And, you know, when they're announcing the nominees, the camera guys just run right up. Right.
Right in your face.
Yeah.
And so it's right in Steve's face and then we're directly behind him.
And when they didn't say his name, I guess I said, motherf-fucker.
I mean, that's the correct response.
Yeah.
And I had one or two friends say, did you say motherfucker?
Right in your face. Yeah. Right in your face. And so it's right in Steve's face and then we're directly behind him. And when they didn't say his name, I guess I said, motherf-fucker. I mean, that's the correct response. Yeah. And I had one or two friends say, did you say motherfucker?
I think I saw you say that.
I'm like, yes, yes, I did.
came out of me. I didn't have a choice. I couldn't believe it. I couldn't. And I, you know,
so many of us couldn't because he was amazing. The other scene in that episode that I think of,
when I think of how great he was, is the one where, so the plot is that he and Dwight decide
that they're going to go to David Wallace's house and just like stop him and like make their
argument why Scranton shouldn't close. And he never shows up. They just end up spending the entire
day outside his house. And he and Dwight are sitting there at the end when it looks like all is
我想我看到你发过那个。我就想，没错，没错，我确实发了。那是自然流露出来的。我别无选择。我简直不敢相信。我真的不敢。而且，你知道，我们很多人都不敢相信，因为他太棒了。那一集中我能想到的另一个场景，每当我想起他有多棒时，就是那个情节是这样的，他和德怀特决定去大卫·华莱士的家里，阻止他，然后向他陈述为什么斯克兰顿分公司不应该关闭的理由。而他根本没现身。他们最后只好一整天都待在他家外面。他和德怀特坐在那里，到了最后，当一切看起来都...
lost and he just says like, all right, top three, what are your top three moments ever,
your three favorite moments at Dundra Mifflin?
And Dwight names a couple, one or two things I think we've seen in the world of the show,
like the concussion, like when Michael took Dwight to the hospital.
And Dwight gets a little emotional.
And there also one thing I think that we didn't see that was a reference to something
that happened before the documentary started shooting.
And then Dwight says, what about you?
无望的时候，他突然说，好吧，排名前三，你这辈子排名前三的时刻是什么，你在邓德米夫林的三个最难忘的时刻？德怀特说出了几个，有一两个我觉得我们在剧里见过的场景，比如脑震荡那次，迈克尔把德怀特送去医院。德怀特有点情绪激动。还有一个我觉得我们没在剧里看到的事情，那是对纪录片开拍前发生的事情的一个致敬。然后德怀特说，你呢？
What are your top three moments?
And he says all of them, every single moment, every single moment was wonderful and perfect and special.
And it's really a beautiful moment.
And then Dwight says, what about when Jan came and told you the office was closing?
And he's like, God damn it, Dwight.
It was so perfect.
Dwight, like, just who he is.
Yeah.
你排名前三的时刻是什么？他说全部，每一个时刻，每一个时刻都是美好、完美和特殊的。这真的是一个非常动人的时刻。然后德怀特说，那简来告诉大家办公室要关门的时候呢？他就像是，该死的，德怀特。真是太完美了。德怀特这个人，就是他本来的样子。是的。
He's so literal.
He's very, he means every single moment?
Well, I can think of one.
Yeah.
He also, they did this great thing where Dwight is going to practice being David Wallace and Michael's going to
plea his case why they can't close
Scranton Branch. And Dwight
just very matter-factly, he's
他太字面主义了。他非常……他意思是每一个时刻吗？好吧，我能想到一个。是的。而且他们还有一个绝妙的桥段，德怀特练习扮演大卫·华莱士，而迈克尔则要为他们为什么不能关闭斯克兰顿分公司进行辩护。而德怀特非常公事公办地，他...
like, well, it's a dying business
for one. And it's like, it's
just comes down to numbers. It's just
math. And he's so matter
of fact. And Michael's like, stop it, stop it.
He's never going to say that. Well, there's
a wonderful moment that was improvised between
the two of them. I think the way it
就说，嗯，首先这是一个垂死的行业。这就好比，这归根结底就是数字问题。这就是数学。他就是这么一板一眼。而迈克尔则说，停下，停下。他绝不会这么说。好吧，他们两人之间有一个即兴发挥的精彩片段。我想最后的方式是...
ended was Michael was like, just start over
and be more scared of me. Yeah.
And so Dwight goes back and he
wasn't supposed to do this, but Rain walked up again.
And Michael says like, David Wallace, and rain goes, ha!
They're like, jumps backwards.
And we had to cut it off.
Literally the frame where we cut it off is the last frame before they both started laughing.
迈克尔说，重来一次，而且要更怕我一点。是的。于是德怀特又来了一遍，他本来不该这么做的，但雷恩又走了过去。迈克尔说，大卫·华莱士，然后雷恩喊道，哈！他们就像是，吓得往后一跳。我们不得不把这里剪掉。我们剪掉的那个画面，正好是他们两个开始大笑之前的最后一帧。
It's a good memory of that moment.
Oh, it was really fun to rewatch it.
I highly recommend, guys.
Well, since we're talking about season three, this is actually a question I wanted to ask you.
The arc of season three is such an impressive arc.
You have the whole storyline of Jim going to Stanford.
You had to create this whole other branch.
You had to fill it with people who were then going to come merge with the Scranton branch.
这是对那个时刻的美好回忆。哦，重温那个片段真的太有趣了。我强烈推荐大家去看。好吧，既然我们在聊第三季，这其实是我一直想问你的一个问题。第三季的剧情走向真的是一个非常宏大的布局。你有吉姆去斯坦福的整条故事线。你们必须凭空创造出另一个分公司。你们必须用那些随后要来与斯克兰顿分公司合并的人来填满它。
And then some of them stay.
Like you had to cast Rashida Jones.
You had to cast Ed Helms.
It was this massive ongoing storyline.
Like, can you talk a little bit about how that was created, like some of the conversations in the room and like how far into the season did you get when we started shooting?
It's a great question.
This was a big swing that Greg decided to make, which.
was at the end of season two after Jim and Pam kiss and Pam sort of lets him down in her mind easy,
然后其中一些人留了下来。比如你们必须挑选拉什达·琼斯。你们必须挑选埃德·海尔姆斯。这是一条庞大且持续发展的故事情节。那么，你们能稍微聊聊这个是怎么构思出来的吗，比如编剧室里的一些讨论，以及在我们开始拍摄时，剧情已经推进到了第几集？这是个好问题。这是格雷格决定做出的一记重击，这记重击...
but for him not very easy.
Greg was like he's got to leave.
We can't just start season three with him back at the office.
It's not sort of following through on the story you've told.
The story we've told is that Jim stays in this office because of Pam.
So if he makes a play for Pam and Pam turns him down, he's going to leave.
So he had a general with Ed, I remember.
Like, and we were all daily show fans.
发生在第二季末尾，在吉姆和帕姆亲吻之后，帕姆在心理上算是轻易地拒绝了他，但对他来说可一点也不轻松。格雷格当时的看法是，他必须离开。我们不能直接让第三季从他回到办公室开始。那样就没法顺理成章地推进你所铺垫的故事了。我们所铺垫的故事是，吉姆留在办公室是因为帕姆。所以，如果他向帕姆表白却被帕姆拒绝，他肯定会离开。因此我记得他和埃德有过一次会面。而且，我们当时都是《每日秀》的粉丝。
And so we were like, oh, Ed Helms is here.
That's fun.
And we came into that season, and Greg was like, Jim is going to leave.
He's going to go to another branch.
We're going to meet an entire group of people who work in that branch.
And then at some point, early in the season, they're going to fold together.
The branches are going to march.
So the important people were Ed's character, Andy Bernard,
所以我们就觉得，哦，埃德·海尔姆斯来了。太有意思了。我们进入那一季的时候，格雷格就说，吉姆要离开。他要去另一个分公司。我们会遇到一群全新的在该分公司工作的人。然后在某个时刻，在这一季的早期，他们会重新融合到一起。分公司会合并。所以重要的人物是埃德的角色，安迪·伯纳德，
Rashida's character, who was going to be Jim's new love interest.
Because Greg was like, when Jim comes back, he's got a girlfriend.
That was a huge thing too.
And then the manager of the office, who was Josh, who was going to play an important role in the story in that he was going to seem like an incredibly competent, like, well functioning, high functioning manager who was clearly better than Michael Scott at managing.
But was also like kind of a self-interested guy who didn't really care about the office and was going to like leverage this corporate upheaval for his own gain, which led to one of my favorite gym lines.
where when that is revealed, when Jim says, like, say what you will about Michael Scott, he would never do that.
Yeah.
Which was like, that was the whole storyline that was laid out.
拉什达的角色，她将成为吉姆的新恋爱对象。因为格雷格的意思是，当吉姆回来时，他已经有女朋友了。这也是个大动作。然后是办公室经理，也就是乔什，他在故事中将扮演一个重要角色，因为他看起来像是一个极其精明能干、运转良好、高效率的经理，在管理能力上明显胜过迈克尔·斯科特。但同时他也像是个利己主义者，并不真的关心办公室，并且会利用这次公司的人事动荡来谋取私利，这就引出了我最喜欢的吉姆的一句台词。当真相大白时，吉姆说，不管你怎么评价迈克尔·斯科特，他是绝对不会干出这种事的。是的。这就是当时铺开的整条故事线。
And Charles Lesson was great.
He was so good.
Yeah.
He was really great.
He was a perfect, just like handsome, charismatic guy who, like everyone was, like, psyched to work for.
And, you know, the hardest part, obviously, like, Ed, you cast because Ed's hilarious.
And, like, he's like a guy who you're like, well, this guy will fold naturally into any ensemble and will be wonderful and great.
Can I say one thing about that episode?
查尔斯·莱森太棒了。他太出色了。是的。他真的很棒。他完美地诠释了一个既帅气又有个人魅力、让所有人都渴望为之效力的家伙。而且，你知道，最难的部分，很显然，像埃德，你选他是因为埃德太搞笑了。而且，他就像那种你会觉得，嗯，这家伙能自然而然地融入任何演员阵容，而且会表现得绝妙无比的人。关于那一集，我能说一件事吗？
When they find out in branch closing that, you know, Scranton is going to be, you know, closed down, he goes up to Jim at the Stanford office and goes, in your face!
Jim's like, I don't work there.
I work here.
Of all of Krasinski's tiny line readings, it's one of the tiniest because he goes, hi, in your face.
And John goes, well, I work here now.
Yeah.
You can barely hear him and speak so quietly.
It's wonderful.
当他们在分公司关闭那一集中发现，你知道，斯克兰顿分公司要被，你知道，关门大吉时，他走到斯坦福分公司的吉姆面前说，活该！吉姆却说，我不在这上班。我在这一上班。在卡拉辛斯基所有微小的台词处理中，这是最微不足道的一句，因为他说，嗨，活该。而约翰却说，嗯，我现在在这上班。是的。你几乎听不清他在说话，声音那么轻。太精彩了。
But anyway, I'm so sorry.
So Ed, obviously.
Ed is like, cast that guy.
He's great.
He's a New England preppy.
Like, I was delighted because Andy Brown is everyone I grew up with in Connecticut.
Like, I was like, oh, I can write this guy forever.
Like, I'm like, wind me up and set me loose.
但不管怎样，真的很抱歉。所以很显然，埃德。埃德就是那种，选定这个家伙。他太棒了。他是个新英格兰的预科生。当时我特别高兴，因为安迪·布朗就是我在康涅狄格州一同长大的所有人。当时我就想，哦，我可以一直为这家伙写剧本。我就像，给我上发条，然后放我出去闯吧。
The hardest part was Rashida, because this is one of the hardest things to do in any show, right,
is there are two people on the show who are soulmates.
It's very clear that they're soulmates.
And they are going to at some point get together.
And Greg was like, if they get together, they're staying together.
We're not doing Ross and Rachel, which they did obviously incredibly effectively over 10 years,
which is like get together, break up, get together, break up over and over again.
He's like, when Jim and Pam get together, they're going to stay together.
最难的部分是拉什达，因为这是任何剧集中最难做的事情之一，对吧，剧里有两个灵魂伴侣。很显然他们是灵魂伴侣。而且他们终究会走到一起。格雷格的看法是，如果他们走到一起，他们就会一直在一起。我们不会搞罗斯和雷切尔那一套，当然他们在10年里把那一套做得极其成功，也就是分分合合、分分合合，一次又一次。他的意思是，当吉姆和帕姆走到一起时，他们就会永远在一起。
He always kind of knew that.
So what we needed for the obstacle was a woman who Jim could date, who was a good match for him.
He also didn't want to do a move, which I think is kind of.
crappy and slightly misogynistic, which is you give the protagonist of the show a girlfriend
who's just a terrible person, either cheats on him or brow beats him or is like selfish or is mean
or whatever. And it's cheap because it makes the audience just like root for Jim and for the person
to go with you with the other person. And Greg was like, that's just fake. Like you know that's fake.
And Greg, he had this very, very Greg like analogy, which is he told the story, I want to say it's
他心里一直很清楚这一点。所以我们需要制造的阻碍是一个女性，一个能和吉姆约会、与他旗鼓相当的女性。他同样不想采用一种我觉得有点……糟糕且略带厌女色彩的套路，也就是给剧中的男主角安排一个极其糟糕的女朋友，要么背叛他，要么对他颐指气使，要么极其自私，或者刻薄等等。这很低级，因为这只会让观众盲目地支持吉姆去和另一个人在一起。而格雷格觉得，那太假了。你知道那都是假的。而且格雷格，他有一个非常非常带有格雷格风格的比喻，他讲了个故事，我想说的是
General Sherman in the Civil War.
It's a classic Greg thing.
Amazing.
Yeah.
Did you tell it while laying on his back stretching his...
A hundred percent he did, yes.
He was lying on the floor, on that dirty floor of the writers' room.
The story from history was that I think it was Sherman.
内战中的谢尔曼将军。这很典型，是格雷格的风格。太棒了。是啊。他是躺在背上舒展着身子说出这个故事的吗？百分之百是的。他躺在地上，在编剧室那张脏兮兮的地板上。历史上的那个故事，我记得好像是谢尔曼。
It might have been Grant.
Or I'm getting all of this wrong.
But it was an army was marching south through the U.S.
and the opposing forces, the Confederate forces, were very skilled fighters.
And even if they were outnumbered, they could win a theoretical battle if they knew where they were going.
So if Sherman were marching on Richmond, Lee would marshal all of his forces in Richmond and be ready for him.
So what Sherman did, according to Greg, was to drive his army halfway between two possible destinations,
halfway between Richmond and Atlanta.
也可能是格兰特。或者我全记错了。但大致是一支军队正向美国南部挺进，而敌方也就是邦联军队，是非常出色的战士。即使他们寡不敌众，如果他们知道对方要去哪里，他们也能赢得理论上的战争。所以如果谢尔曼向里士满进军，李将军就会把所有的兵力调集到里士满并做好准备。因此，根据格雷格的说法，谢尔曼所做的就是把他的军队开到两个可能目的地正中间，也就是里士满和亚特兰大正中间。
So Lee would then have to send half of his army to Richmond and half to Atlanta,
and then at the last second, Sherman would break towards one of them,
and then he would only have to fight half of the Southern Army and would win.
And he used this analogy by saying, like,
we have to create a girlfriend for Jim,
who is compelling enough and a good enough match that half of our audience is rooting for him
to say, I'm sorry, Pam, you missed your shot.
and half of the audience is rooting for him to say, like, get rid of this lady and go with Pam.
这样一来，李将军就必须把一半军队派往里士满，另一半派往亚特兰大，然后在最后一秒，谢尔曼突然向其中一个方向发起进攻，这样他就只需要与半个南方军队作战就能取胜。他用这个比喻说，我们必须为吉姆创造一个女朋友，她要有足够的吸引力、足够般配，以至于有一半的观众支持吉姆对她说：“对不起，潘，你错失良机了。”而另一半的观众则支持他对她说：“甩了这个女人，跟潘在一起吧。”
And so that required a lot of things.
One, some good stories where Rashida was funny and interesting and compelling and smart and cool.
And it required an actor to play that role that people wouldn't hate.
And so we looked forever.
We tried so many different versions of like just combing through the other shows and seeing like what actors have been on these shows who seem good.
and funny and whatever.
I met Rashida in my second day of college,
and we've been friends ever since.
这就需要很多条件。第一，要有精彩的故事，让拉什达显得有趣、引人入胜、聪明又酷。第二，需要一个演员来扮演这个角色，让人们不会讨厌她。于是我们找了很久。我们尝试了各种各样的版本，比如翻遍其他剧集，看看有哪些演员在这些剧里表现不错、很有趣之类。我和拉什达在大二的第二天就认识了，从那以后我们一直是朋友。
And so I was obviously, like, quietly being like, cast Rashida.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then she had met John already,
and so John liked her and was, like, pushing for her.
But Greg famously indecisive in these moments,
or I guess the indecisive is not the nicest way to say it.
Thurow would be the nicest way to put it,
that he exhausts every avenue of possibility.
所以当时我显然在默默地想：“选拉什达吧。”对，对，对。然后她已经见过约翰了，所以约翰很喜欢她，一直在力挺她。但格雷格在这些时刻出了名的优柔寡断，或者说，优柔寡断并不是最好听的说法。深思熟虑或许是最好的形容，他会穷尽所有的可能性。
And we looked and looked and looked
and eventually settled on Rashida.
And then the challenge became, in like six episodes, introduce her and build her into a person who, at least some of the audience, was like, wait, I think she's a better girlfriend for Jim than Pam is.
And that was really hard.
And that took, like, most of the time of the writer's room and the time between season two and season three was spent just doing that.
Like, how can we, like, meticulously form a character that audiences are rooting for?
It was very hard.
You know what I think worked about it is that I liked Karen as a woman.
我们找了又找，看了又看了，最后定下了拉什达。接下来的挑战是，在差不多六集的时间里介绍她，把她塑造成这样一个角色：至少有一部分观众会觉得“等等，我觉得她比潘更适合当吉姆的女朋友”。这真的很难。编剧室的大部分时间和第二季到第三季之间的间隙，基本上都花在做这件事上了。比如，我们如何精心塑造一个让观众支持的角色？这太难了。你知道我觉得这个角色成功的地方在哪里吗？我喜欢作为女性的卡伦。
Like I wanted to go to lunch with Karen.
I wanted to be friends with Karen.
I'm like, oh, this is a woman I'd want to spend time with.
She's cool.
Yeah.
And they seemed like exactly what you're saying.
Like Jim and Karen seemed like a couple who were compatible enough and had enough fun that they'd have like a three-year relationship and then break up.
Right.
就像我想和卡伦一起吃午饭。我想和卡伦做朋友。我觉得，哦，这是一个我想和她共度时光的女性。她很酷。对。而且他们看起来就像你刚才说的。吉姆和卡伦看起来就像是一对足够般配、玩得很开心、会谈三年恋爱然后分手的伴侣。没错。
You know?
Like Pam aside.
Jim was not going to end up with Karen in the long run.
Right.
Whenever he met her.
But this was like a solid choice.
This was like a person to spend three years of your time with.
你知道吗？抛开潘不谈。从长远来看，吉姆是不可能和卡伦走到一起的。没错。无论他什么时候遇到她。没错。但这确实是个扎实的选择。这是一个适合和你共度三年时光的人。
Yeah, she was cool.
She was smart.
She was good at her job.
She was funny.
Yeah.
A huge breakthrough for the writers was the Christmas episode that year, which was extended,
which Jen Salada wrote, I want to say, and which was so good.
And Harold Ramos, the late Harold Ramos directed.
对，她很酷。她很聪明。她工作能力很强。她很有趣。对。对编剧们来说，当年那集圣诞特别篇是个巨大的突破，那一集篇幅较长，我想是珍·萨拉达写的，非常精彩。已故的哈罗德·雷米斯执导了这一集。
and was so good that it was the first time that the cut came in at like 42 minutes, as it always did.
And instead of cutting it down to 2130, Greg went to the studio and was like, we should make this a two-part or we should make this an hour.
And we ended up shooting another, like, writing and shooting another like six or eight minutes of stuff in order to then boil it down to the best 43.
But the plot that mattered so much was that Karen and Pam were on the same team.
Yeah.
It was like Churchill, right?
Like nothing brings people together like a common enemy.
而且拍得太好了，这是剪辑出来的初剪版本第一次达到了42分钟，就像往常一样。格雷格没有把它剪短到21分30秒，而是去了电视台说：“我们应该把它拍成上下集，或者做成一个小时的特辑。”结果我们又拍摄了——也就是写了并拍摄了大约六到八分钟的内容，然后把它精简到最好的43分钟。但那个极其重要的情节是，卡伦和潘站在了同一边。对。对。就像丘吉尔一样，对吧？没有什么能像共同的敌人那样把人们团结在一起。
Yes.
And so there you were.
And like that, but that pitching out that story was a huge relief for us because we were like, right,
the story of this doesn't have to be a rivalry between Pam and Karen.
It can be that like you said, that like Pam is like, I kind of like this lady.
Like I want to be friends of there.
Like legitimately.
是的。所以你们就在那里了。是的。就像那样，但是理清那个故事对我们来说是一种巨大的解脱，因为我们觉得，对，这个故事不一定非得是潘和卡伦之间的敌对关系。它可以像你说的，潘会觉得“我其实挺喜欢这位女士的。我想和她做朋友”。发自内心地，
not as a way to like weasel my way back into Jim's life,
but just because for Pam, life in that office could be pretty lonely
in terms of like ladies that you can hang out with and talk to.
And suddenly here's one right here and she's cool.
And so in the like slow, deliberate sort of brick by brick construction of Karen as a character,
that was like a huge moment that we were like,
oh, there should be an episode where they happily and joyfully find themselves on the same team.
I think shout out too to Rashida,
而不是为了“我想重新挤回吉姆的生活”而耍小聪明，纯粹是因为对潘来说，在那个办公室里，从能一起闲逛、聊天女性的角度来看，生活可能会相当孤独。而突然之间这里就有一个，而且她很酷。因此，在对卡伦这个角色进行缓慢、深思熟虑、一砖一瓦式的构建中，那是一个巨大的时刻，我们当时想，哦，应该有一集，她们高兴且愉快地发现自己站在了同一边。我觉得也要感谢拉什达，
because she just has a natural presence as Karen that puts you at ease.
And that's her just instincts as an actor.
And then also in real life, she is one of the coolest people you'll ever meet.
That's the thing.
She is.
Like, you know, I took a trip with her.
Like, we've talked about this before.
I went and did this work with this nonprofit that helps save the world's oceans.
因为作为卡伦，她天生有一种能让人放松下来的气场。这完全是她作为演员的直觉。而且在现实生活中，她也是你见过的最酷的人之一。事实就是如此。她真的是。比如，你知道的，我和她一起去旅行过。我们以前也聊过这个。我曾和这个旨在拯救世界海洋的非营利组织一起工作。
And Rashid and I went together.
And there are still things she said as we traveled to Belize, like, that I still say to people.
Like, she...
Emotionally expensive.
That's one of them.
She said, I kind of was like going through some stuff and she was like, Angel, that person is too emotionally expensive for you.
And I was like, what?
This is brilliant.
我和拉什达一起去了。在我们前往伯利兹的旅途中，她说过的一些话，直到现在我还在对别人说。比如她……情感消耗太大。这是其中之一。她说，我当时好像经历了一些事情，她就说：“安吉尔，那个人对你的情感消耗太大了。”然后我说：“什么？这太绝了。”
The other thing is, she gets on a plane.
She's like a professional.
Yeah.
She has so many lotions.
And she hydrates.
And she's like, my friends call me lotions and potions on planes.
So now I like bring like hand lotion and chapstick like on a plane and I think of her.
还有一件事，她上飞机时就像个专业人士。对。她有超级多的乳液。对。而且她很注重补水。她说：“我的朋友们在飞机上叫我‘乳液与药水大王’。”所以现在我上飞机也会带润手霜和润唇膏，然后我就会想起她。
She was, I mean, again, I'm coming from a medium-sized town in suburban Connecticut.
But even so, when I met her on the second day of freshman year of college in 1993,
she was the coolest person I'd ever met.
And now, 33 years later, she is still the coolest person I've ever met.
Well, I think to wrap up this part of our office convo, we wanted to ask you.
And this is like kind of one of those questions.
Like when people ask me, I'm like, oh, it's so hard.
But do you have an episode that you wrote that's,
我的意思是，再次声明，我来自康涅狄格州郊区的一个中等规模的小镇。即便如此，当我1993年在大学大一的第二天遇到她时，她是我见过的最酷的人。现在，33年过去了，她依然是我见过的最酷的人。好吧，我想为我们这次办公室对话的这一部分做个结尾，我们想问你一个问题。这有点像那种问题。每当别人问我时，我都觉得太难了。不过，你有没有哪一集是你写过并且觉得...
near and dear to your heart?
I mean, all of them, obviously.
I will say branch closing, I was very delighted in how it all turned out.
I think the one that I think of the most is the negotiation, which was one of the
supersized ones, which I was so happy about because there was so much going on.
It's the one that starts with Dwight spraying Mace and Pam's boyfriend and stopping
an attack. And Angela's titillated
by it. It keeps having everyone
让你记忆犹新？我是说，显然所有的都很棒。不过我要说的是“分部倒闭”，我对它的整体呈现效果感到非常高兴。我认为我想到最多的还是“谈判”那一集，那是那些超长集数中的一集，我对此感到非常高兴，因为里面发生了太多事情。就是以德怀特向梅斯喷防狼喷雾、保护帕姆的男朋友并阻止袭击开场的那一集。安吉拉对此感到很兴奋。大家一直在
retell the story. So this was
the best part of it was Roy
comes in and Dwight mases him.
He's about to attack Jim
and maces him. And
that's a great beginning to an episode,
right? That's so exciting.
And then a bunch of stuff has to
重述这个故事。所以这集最棒的部分就是罗伊进来了，德怀特用防狼喷雾喷了他。他正要袭击吉姆，然后德怀特就喷了他。这是一集绝佳的开场，对吧？太激动人心了。然后一堆事情由此
branch out of that. And because
the story that we had for Michael was that
Daryl wanted to renegotiate his salary
because Roy had been fired and now he
was like, okay, I'm stepping up.
and whatever.
And so that whole thing, that whole story is huge.
And they go to the corporate offices and he talks to Jan.
衍生出来。因为我们为迈克尔设定的剧情是，达里尔想要重新谈判薪资，因为罗伊被解雇了，现在他觉得自己该挑起大梁了，诸如此类。所以整条故事线，整个故事非常宏大。他们去了总公司，他跟简谈了谈。
And it also flips and Daryl finds out how much Michael makes and is like humiliated for him.
And it's like, you got to get a raise, but I can get a raise, you know.
And it's a real Craig Robinson showcased that whole episode.
But then the B story was Jim feeling like he owed Dwight a debt of gratitude and was like,
how do I pay this guy back?
and he tries all these silly ways to pay Dwight back.
And Dwight, in his weird coat of honor,
is refusing to accept a payback
而且剧情还来个大反转，达里尔发现了迈克尔的薪水有多少，并为他感到羞耻。这就好比，你得去加薪啊，不过我倒能去加薪，你知道的。克雷格·罗宾逊在整集中简直是演技大爆发。但随后的B线剧情是吉姆觉得自己欠了德怀特一个人情，心想我该怎么报答这家伙？于是他尝试了各种愚蠢的办法去报答德怀特。而德怀特凭借他那奇特的荣誉感，拒绝接受报答，
because he says citizens do not accept prizes
for being citizens, is that way he puts it.
So both of those stories were so great.
It was like, put Michael Scott and Craig Robinson
in a room together and like send them off,
and it's going to be great.
And also, Jim feeling a debt to Dwight
that he's trying desperately to fill
因为他说公民不因身为公民而接受奖励，他是这么表达的。所以这两条故事线都太棒了。这就好比，把迈克尔·斯科特和克雷格·罗宾逊关在一个房间里让他们自由发挥，效果绝对好极了。而且，吉姆对德怀特心存感激，拼命想要偿还，
because he hates the feeling of owing Dwight something,
fantastic.
The problem was,
The best episodes of the show were always ones where everyone was involved.
And you're talking about two huge stories where it's just Michael and Craig, really, Toby at the end.
And then Dwight and Jim.
And so this was a risky maneuver.
But on my own, when I went off to write it, I was like, I'm going to add another story.
因为他讨厌这种欠德怀特东西的感觉，简直棒极了。问题在于，这部剧最棒的剧集总是那些全员参与的。而你说的这两条宏大的故事线，实际上只有迈克尔和克雷格，最后加上托比。然后是德怀特和吉姆。所以这是一个冒险的举动。但在我自己着手编写时，我心想，我要再加一条故事线。
And the story was that Angela heard the tale of heroism for Dwight and was like turned on by it.
And kept asking other people to like, well, I didn't really hear what.
happen. Can you repeat the story? And she's doing like fingering, playing her necklace. Yeah.
And then the wonderful thing that came out of it was that Jim had hit a wall where he just couldn't
figure out how to pay Dwight back. And he came out of the bathroom at the end and saw Dwight,
because Angela has gone up to Dwight and been like, I've heard of some incredible tales of heroism.
And there's no one in the office, they think, and they start making out. And Jim sees it. And he gets so
excited and he's like, I, and then he realizes and says, I'm never going to say a word. And that is how I will
这条故事线就是安吉拉听说了德怀特的英雄事迹，对此产生了性冲动。并且一直缠着别人问，呃，我其实没太听清到底发生了什么。你能再讲一遍这个故事吗？她当时一边玩着项链，做着小动作。对。然后发生了一件美妙的事，那就是吉姆遇到了瓶颈，实在想不出该怎么报答德怀特。他最后从洗手间出来时看到了德怀特，因为安吉拉走到德怀特身边说，我听说了一些不可思议的英雄事迹。他们以为办公室里没人了，于是开始热吻。吉姆看到了这一幕。他兴奋极了，心想，我……然后他意识到并说道，我永远不会吐露半个字。这就是我将如何
pay Dwight back. And it was like the perfect like dovetailing of stories that involve like everyone in the
office entirely. And so the way that all kind of coalesced into a big giant fun story. And then we had
this wonderful thing for like another bunch of episodes, which was that Dwight thought that no one knew.
and Jim, his worst enemy, knew this thing and wasn't telling anyone.
And I think it just made Jim really likable.
And he was like doing a nice thing without Dwight knowing it,
which was just like a really sweet little backstory, you know.
Aw.
报答德怀特的方式。这简直就像是各种故事的完美融合，办公室里的每个人都完全参与其中。所以这一切如何融合成一个宏大、有趣的大故事。然后我们在接下来的好几集中都有了一个美妙的设定，那就是德怀特以为没人知道。而吉姆，他最大的死敌，知道了这件事却谁也没说。我觉得这让吉姆非常讨人喜欢。他在德怀特不知情的情况下做了一件好事，这就成了一个非常温馨的小背景故事，你知道的。天哪。
Yeah.
I love that.
Yeah, that one was really fun.
And I was so happy that it was supersized because it allowed us to keep all that stuff in the episode.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
You are so, like, just fun to talk to.
You are.
对。我太喜欢了。没错，那一集真的超级有趣。我很高兴它是超长版，因为这让我们得以把所有这些内容都保留在剧集里。天啊。你真的，太好聊天了。你确实是。
You're just, you're smart and you remember things.
Well, that's, I mean, look, I've said this the last time I was here.
Like, that show was so formative for all of us.
Like, it taught me everything I've ever learned about writing and about story creation and about working with actors and all that stuff.
Like, it was such a vibrant laboratory is how I think about it.
Like, Greg threw us into the deep end of the pool in the best way.
You know, I'd never written on anything before.
And there I was, like, on the set, like, dealing with directors and talking to actors and, like, in the edit bay, like, making editing decisions.
你很聪明，而且记性很好。好吧，我的意思是，听着，我上次来的时候就说过。这部剧对我们所有人都影响深远。它教会了我关于编剧、故事创作、与演员合作以及所有这些事情所能学到的一切。它就像是一个充满活力的实验室，我是这么看待它的。格雷格以最好的方式把我们扔进了深水区。你知道的，我以前从来没写过任何东西。然而我就那样站在片场，跟导演打交道，和演员交流，还在剪辑室里参与剪辑决策。
I didn't know that isn't typical.
And now, you know, 20, 30 years later, I'm realizing how atypical it really was.
And so I've tried in my life now running different shows to replicate that process.
It's not easy.
It requires a lot of faith in the people that you hire, and it requires a lot of time to walk people through all of the mistakes that they make when they don't know what they're doing.
Like, we all made horrible mistakes and, like, wasted enormous.
amounts of time making terrible editing decisions. And even then I was aware of how special it was,
the lessons I learned and the moments that stood out, like, are very deeply embedded in my brain.
我当时不知道这并不是常态。现在，20、30年过去了，我才意识到它实际上是多么不寻常。所以我现在在管理不同剧集的生活中，一直试图复制那个过程。这并不容易。它需要对你雇用的人有极大的信任，并且需要大量时间来引导大家走过他们因不知自己在做什么而犯下的所有错误。就像我们都犯过可怕的错误，在做出糟糕的剪辑决定上浪费了大量的时间。即便在当时，我也意识到它是多么特别，我学到的教训以及那些脱颖而出的时刻，都深深地烙印在我的脑海里。
And I don't think they'll ever leave. You know, I'm really moved by you saying that.
Like, I got a little choked up because it is such a gift that Greg gave all of us, the actors,
to bringing us into the process so intimately. Like, I left that show a better actor because I knew.
everything that was happening besides just my acting.
Because he brought us into the edit bay and into conversations and into the writer's room.
And so seeing how a story was crafted and why it was important and like little things.
Like I don't know.
Like you get a line or you get a scene and you're like, I don't get it.
我想它们永远不会离开。你知道的，你这么说真的很让我感动。我有点哽咽了，因为这是格雷格赐予我们所有演员的巨大礼物，他让我们如此亲密地参与到创作过程中。离开这部剧时，我成了一名更好的演员，因为除了我自己的表演之外，我对发生的一切都了如指掌。因为他把我们带进了剪辑室、带进了讨论中、带进了编剧室。所以能看到一个故事是如何构思出来的，为什么它很重要，还有一些小细节。比如，我不知道。比如你拿到了一句台词或一场戏，然后你想，我不明白。
Like he didn't just say do it because I wrote it.
He'd be like, let me tell you where we're going with this.
Yeah.
And you're like, oh, I gotcha.
It was obvious to me very early.
I think I told this story the first time I was on your show,
but my meeting with him was like two hours long,
and it was very different from all the other meetings I'd taken.
他不会只是说“按我写的演就行”。他会说，让我告诉你我们这样做的用意。对。然后你会想，哦，我明白了。我从很早开始就看得很清楚。我想我第一次上你的节目时就讲过这个故事，但我跟他的会面持续了大约两个小时，这与我参加过的所有其他会面截然不同。
And I sent my agent an email when I left,
and said, I don't know if that guy's going to offer me a job,
but if he does, I'm going to take it,
because I think he's going to teach me how to write.
And he did offer me the job, and I did take it,
and he did teach me how to write.
And so I knew from the beginning that this was, like, a person I could learn from.
And then, like, the process of that first season
我离开时给我的经纪人发了一封邮件，说我不知道那家伙会不会给我提供一份工作，但如果他给的话，我一定会接受，因为我觉得他会教我怎么写作。他确实给了我工作，我也确实接受了，他也确实教会了我怎么写作。所以我从一开始就知道，这是一个我可以向他学习的人。然后，第一季的整个过程，
of, like, breaking stories and slogging through all
these different versions and everything sort of, you know, made it clear. But then the first episode
I wrote was The Alliance and he was like editing it and I was working on the comeback, this first
season of the show, The Comeback on HBO at the time. And so I wasn't able to be around a lot.
And he was like, hey, we just finished our first assembly of the Alliance and I'm going to send it to you so
you can look at it. So I watched it and it was completely different. Obviously it was completely different.
The first cut was 38 minutes long and this one was 24 or whatever.
whatever. And I remember watching it and like my heart sinking because I was like, wait, he cut
比如构思故事、在各种不同版本中艰难摸索，等等，你知道的，这一切都让事情变得明朗起来。但我写的第一集是《结盟》，当时他正在剪辑这一集，而我当时正在做HBO的第一季电视剧《归来》。所以我没法经常在场。他说，嘿，我们刚完成了《结盟》的第一版初剪，我要把它发给你看看。于是我看了，它完全变了。显而易见，它完全变了。初剪版长达38分钟，而这一集是24分钟左右，诸如此类。我记得我看着它，心直往下沉，因为我想，等等，他剪掉了
this and he cut that and he moved this scene over here. And I like panicked. And I wrote him this
long email where I was like, hey, so here's just a few thoughts on like, on this and like you cut
the cold open and the cold open really does this thing where it sets up this. And you also,
you know, by starting this scene here, you do blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I remember sending it off and being like when he reads this, he's going to rethink some of this
decisions.
And he wrote back and I remember it so clearly he wrote like, hey dude, exclamation point.
Like responses below, see if they make sense to you.
这个，他剪掉了那个，他把这场戏移到了这里。我恐慌了。我给他写了一封很长的邮件，大意是：嘿，所以关于这个，我有几个想法，比如你剪掉了冷场开场，而冷场开场真的很棒，它铺垫了这一点。而且你还知道，通过从这里开始这场戏，你做了巴拉巴拉巴拉……我记得我把邮件发了出去，心想等他读了这封信，他会重新考虑其中一些决定的。他回信了，我记得太清楚了，他写道：嘿，老兄，后面带个惊叹号。回复在下方，看看它们对你有没有道理。
And then just one by one, everything I had said, he like took the time to write out a long
paragraph of like, here's why I did this and here's why it's good, I think, and here's why
it makes sense and here's why it helps the episode.
And then I remember it was like my heart like sank again somehow because I was embarrassed,
but also like rose back up into my chest
because I was like, oh, this guy knows everything.
Like this guy is seeing the matrix code
behind the show in a way that I could never
然后，针对我说的每一句话，他都不厌其烦地写了一大段话，解释“我为什么这么做，为什么我认为这很好，为什么它说得通，为什么它对这集有帮助”。然后我记得我的心不知怎么的又往下沉了一下，因为我感到很尴尬，但同时也重新涌上了胸口，因为我想，哦，这家伙无所不知。这家伙能看透这部剧背后的黑客帝国代码，而我在我人生的这个阶段，
in this moment in my life.
And I just remember thinking, like,
there is nothing that I could suggest to Greg Daniels
that he has not already thought about.
He knew the show from beginning to end
before he started working on it somehow.
And like, when you know that you're in the hands of someone
who cares that much and knows that much about what he's doing,
永远也做不到这一点。我只记得当时在想，格雷格·丹尼尔斯绝对能想到所有我甚至无法建议他的事情。在他开始创作之前，他不知怎么地就已经对这部剧了如指掌，从头到尾。而且，当你明知自己身处一个如此在乎、对自己的工作如此精通的人手中时，
It's so freeing.
You're just like, I just trust that the decisions that are being made are like coming from a place of like thoughtfulness and understanding and like love of the characters and love of the world that makes me just very at ease, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
He's smart and thoughtful and funny.
Oh my gosh, all the things.
The one thing he said to me about my character, and I don't know if I've shared this before, but there was a moment where we didn't know if we were going to be.
series regulars are not, you know, the supporting cast. And I think I just sort of insecurely just
said to him without even thinking, I don't know if my character brings much, you know.
那种感觉太解放了。你会觉得，我完全相信所做出的决定都源于深思熟虑、相互理解以及对角色和这个世界的爱，这让我感到非常放松，你知道的？对，对。他既聪明、体贴又幽默。天哪，所有的优点全占了。他对我饰演的角色说过唯一的一件事——我不知道我以前有没有分享过，但当时我们并不知道自己是否会成为剧集的常规演员，还是仅仅作为配角。我想我当时只是有些不够自信地随口对他说了一句，我不知道我的角色能带来多少价值，你知道的。
And he said, oh, Angela, your character's the bitch. You always need the bitch. It's like,
no, that's a very good, that's a good character. And I was like, okay, okay. Maybe I'll be around a
Did we talk about the Secret Santa Christmas episode about Angela specifically the last time I was here?
I can't remember.
This is like one of the great writing lessons.
I feel like every time I was in that room, I learned something about how to write.
But I had to write the Yankee Swap Christmas, the Secret Santa Christmas episode.
So I did this thing where I did a real drawing.
他说，哦，安吉拉，你的角色就是那个碧池。你总是需要一个碧池。这就好，这绝对是个好角色。然后我说，好吧，好吧。也许我还能多待一阵子？我们上次我来的时候聊过关于秘密圣诞老人的圣诞那一集，尤其是关于安吉拉的部分吗？我不记得了。这就像是绝佳的编剧课之一。我觉得每次我坐在那个房间里，都能学到一些关于如何写作的知识。但我得写“交换礼物”那个圣诞节，也就是秘密圣诞老人的那一集。所以我当时做了一件事，我真的搞了一场抽签。
I took, I put everyone's names into a hat.
And we knew that like for the plot, like Jim had to have Pam because he was going to get her the teapot.
and Michael had to have Ryan because he gave him the video iPod,
but everything else was up in the air.
So I did a real drawing in my house when I went off to write the script.
And I forget who had Angela.
But anyway, the point is that the person who got Angela,
it wasn't a plot point.
我把每个人的名字都放进了一顶帽子里。我们都知道，为了剧情需要，吉姆必须抽到帕姆，因为他要送她茶壶；迈克尔必须抽到 Ryan，因为他要送他视频 iPod，但其他所有人的分配都是未知的。所以当我去写剧本的时候，我在自己家里真正地抽了签。我忘了是谁抽到了安吉拉。不过总之，重点是抽到安吉拉的那个人，这并不是剧情的关键点。
It was just like we were just needed people to open gifts, right?
And so the gift that I wrote in was like one of those sort of like Joel Osteen sort of like Christian books,
like self-help books or whatever.
And I think it's because Angela had said in the fire episode,
it was like when you're playing, you know,
what books would you have in Desert Island?
She says, she mentions one of those books.
And so I was like, okay, so the person will just get her one of those books.
这只是因为我们需要有人来拆礼物，对吧。所以我写的礼物是那种类似乔尔·欧斯汀的基督教书籍、自助类书籍之类的东西。我想这是因为安吉拉在“火灾”那一集里说过，当你在玩“如果流落荒岛你会带什么书”的游戏时，她提到了其中一本书。所以我当时想，好吧，那这个人就送她其中一本书好了。
And Greg was like, we need to change that when I turned in the script.
And I was like, why?
Like, it's in universe.
You know, she's already said she likes those books.
And he's like, yeah, but that's the reason we need to change it.
He said, like, every episode of every TV show,
you should learn something new about every character.
if you can.
当我交上剧本时，格雷格说我们需要改一下。我说，为什么？这符合剧中设定。你知道的，她已经说过她喜欢那些书。他说，对，但这正是我们需要修改的原因。他说，就像每部电视剧的每一集一样，如果可以的话，你应该让观众对每个角色都有新的了解。
Like, that should be the goal,
that you move the ball
slightly down the field
of, like, character development
for as many people as you can,
because that's what leads to, like,
rich characters, right?
And I was a little bit, like,
这应该成为我们的目标，即尽可能多地为每个人在角色发展上稍微向前推进一点，因为这才能塑造出饱满立体的人物，对吧？我当时有点觉得，
what does this matter?
Like, this episode is so complicated already.
And, like, this is not a plot point.
This doesn't matter.
Like, it's just a moment
where Angela opens a gift
and then we move on.
But we, of course,
这有什么大不了的？这一集已经够复杂的了。而且，这又不是什么剧情关键点。这根本无所谓。这不过是安吉拉拆开一个礼物然后我们继续往下演的一个场面而已。但我们当然，
put, like, seven hours of thought into it
and ended up with buying
that someone gets Angela
a poster of the base
dressed up like humans of like dressed up like adults, right?
Yes.
And first of all, immediately it's like, well, that's way funnier.
It's a way funnier little moment.
花了大约七个小时来思考这个问题，最后买了一个礼物——有人送给安吉拉一张海报，上面画着低音吉他手们打扮成人类、打扮成成年人的模样，对吧？是的。首先，立竿见影的效果就是，这显然搞笑多了。这是一个有趣得多的小片段。
If it's just that moment, it's much better than just a book because who cares.
But then, whatever, 10 episodes later, that poster becomes the centerpiece of an entire
other episode.
Yes.
And suddenly Oscar is wearing it as a shirt.
Because it's, and it was just such a great lesson because it's like, right, even if it doesn't
matter in the moment, like make it as interesting as possible and say something new about each
如果仅仅是那个场面，它也比单纯是一本书要好得多，因为谁在乎一本书。但随后，不管怎样，10集之后，那张海报成了整整另一集的中心道具。没错。突然之间，奥斯卡穿着印有它图案的衬衫。没错。因为它是……这真是一个绝佳的教训，因为这就对了，哪怕它在当下无关紧要，也要把它变得尽可能有趣，并且对每个角色传达出一些新的东西，
character because you don't know how that's going to pay off down the line. And that poster
became like a very important thing in the world of the show. And it's just because he cared at
that granular level of like make every moment one percent better. And then suddenly the entire
episode is like 15 percent better. And the entire season is like 30 percent better. And future
episodes are 500% better. And that's the level of detail that he was putting into all of that
story breaking work. Oh, wow. That was a great specific example of that. Yeah. That's awesome.
Well, Mike, we also want to talk to you about your book. Great. Yes. Okay. Mike has a new book. Yes.
It is called Big Fan and you wrote it with your friend in an amazing sports writer, Joe Posnanski.
因为你永远不知道它在未来会如何发挥作用。而那张海报最终成了这部剧世界观中非常重要的东西。这全是因为他在那种细颗粒度的层面上精益求精——让每个时刻都提升百分之一。然后突然之间，整集节目就提升了百分之十五。整季节目提升了百分之三十。而未来的剧集则提升了百分之五百。这就是他投入到所有故事构思工作中的细节水准。哦，天哪。这真是一个极好的具体例子。没错。太棒了。好了，迈克尔，我们还想跟你聊聊你的书。太棒了。好的。迈克尔出了一本新书。是的。书名叫《铁杆粉丝》（Big Fan），是你和你的朋友、一位了不起的体育作家乔·波兹纳斯基（Joe Posnanski）合著的。
That's right. And I did read this little blurb and I thought I would share it with our list.
so they can get an idea of the book.
It says bestselling authors and podcast hosts.
Joe and Mike love games, almost any games,
and they bring readers to the front row
and sometimes even right onto the field,
whether ringside at WrestleMania in Las Vegas,
singing along with the maniacs at the World Darts Championships
没错。我确实读了这段小简介，我想把它分享给我们的听众。这样他们就能对这本书有所了解。简介说：畅销书作家兼播客主持人乔和迈克热爱比赛，几乎所有的比赛，他们把读者带到第一排，有时甚至直接带到赛场上，无论是在拉斯维加斯摔角狂热大赛的场边，还是在伦敦世界飞镖锦标赛上与狂热的球迷一起引吭高歌，
in London, are just watching eight straight hours of football
at a Buffalo Wild Wings in Dallas.
They bring us to the very heart of what it means
to love something so much it hurts.
I got this book for Lee for Father's Day.
Did you really?
Yes, I did.
Yes, and my son has already stolen it.
亦或是在达拉斯的布法罗狂野翅膀餐厅连续观看八小时的橄榄球比赛。他们带我们领略了深深热爱某事直到心痛的真正含义。我给李买这本书作为父亲节礼物。真的吗？是的，我买了。而且我儿子已经把它偷走了。
Great.
I got it for myself, and I was on a flight to Utah, and I started reading it, and the man
next to me was like, what's that?
Look at you.
I don't know his name.
You're doing Dutton's marketing work for them.
Exactly.
One person at the time.
太棒了。我给自己买了一本，当时我在去犹他州的航班上开始阅读，旁边的人问我，那是什么书？瞧瞧你。我不知道他的名字。你可真是在为邓顿出版社做营销工作。完全正确。一次服务一个人。
Tell us about this book and how it came about.
So a couple years ago, I was sent a video by a friend of mine who said,
look at this, it's hilarious, and it was a video of the World Darts Championship in London,
a thing I did not know existed.
And in the video, a couple, like, very stocky European gentlemen with no expressions on their faces
are just playing darts, or just throwing darts at a dartboard.
And they seem to be doing fairly well because behind them is a crowd of people, like 3,000
people.
跟我们讲讲这本书以及它是怎么构思出来的吧。所以几年前，我的一个朋友给我发了一段视频，说，看这个，太搞笑了。那是一段伦敦世界飞镖锦标赛的视频，这是一个我以前不知道它存在的活动。视频中，几个身材魁梧、面无表情的欧洲绅士正在打飞镖，或者说只是向飞镖盘投掷飞镖。他们似乎投得还不错，因为他们身后是一群人，大约有3000人。
And with every throw, they are absolutely losing their minds.
Like, they just are going, like, crazier and crazier, it's escalating.
And the announcer is with like the thickest, like, I think Scottish accent you've ever heard is like losing his mind.
And it's a very funny juxtaposition of just like no expression, just like thunk, thunk, thunk.
And people go like, and then I start to realize that the crowd behind them are all in costume, different costumes.
Some of them are dressed like Harry Potter.
Some of them are minions.
Some of them are the Jamaican bobsled team.
而且随着每一次投掷，他们简直要疯狂了。就像，他们变得越来越疯狂，情绪不断升级。解说员用着你听过的最浓重的苏格兰口音，简直快要抓狂了。这形成了一种非常有趣的对比：一边是毫无表情的动作，就像‘砰、砰、砰’这样机械的投掷，而人们则在一旁大喊大叫。然后我开始意识到，他们身后的观众都穿着各种各样的服装。有些打扮成哈利·波特，有些是小黄人，还有些是牙买加雪车队队员。
Some of them are dressed like giant bananas or tomatoes or British barristers with like white wigs on.
And I was just like, what is this?
What is this event?
And I was laughing so hard at how crazy it was.
And by the way, by the end, they're literally like jumping up and down and throwing pictures of beer in the air and throwing napkins up and hugging each other.
And I was like, these people are lunatics.
And then I was like, but also that's probably kind of how I look to like my wife when I'm watching sports that I'm.
I care about.
有些人穿着巨大的香蕉、西红柿服装，或者戴着白假发的英国大律师装扮。我当时就在想：这到底是什么？这是什么活动？它疯狂的程度让我笑得前仰后合。顺便说一句，到了最后，他们简直就像是在上下蹦跳，把一杯杯啤酒扔向空中，把餐巾纸扔来扔去，还互相拥抱。我当时想：这些人简直是疯子。紧接着我又想：但话说回来，当我观看自己在乎的体育比赛时，我在我妻子眼里大概也是这副德行吧。
Like, it does make you crazy to be a fan.
And I just had this idea that my friend Joe, who I've known forever, who's a legendary
sports writer, that he and I should go to a bunch of kind of strange events, not the Super Bowl
and the World Series and stuff like that, but like weird events where fans really care.
And just try to figure out if there is something universal about fandom.
Like, is it the same at the World Darts Championship as it is at a Dodgers game?
what is it about fandom that
that matters so much to so many people?
作为一个体育迷，这种狂热确实会让你变疯。我当时就有了这样一个想法：我和我的老朋友乔（我认识他很久了，是一位传奇体育作家）应该一起去参加各种奇奇怪怪的活动——不是超级碗、世界大赛那种，而是那种粉丝真正狂热的奇特活动。我们想试着弄清楚，粉丝文化背后是不是有什么共通的东西？世界飞镖锦标赛和道奇队的比赛，两者的粉丝心理是一样的吗？到底是什么让粉丝文化对这么多人来说如此重要？
Why do so many people
put their lives on hold
and carve time out of their busy days
and stare frantically at a TV screen
and like pace around in their living rooms
and bite their nails
and fall into deep spells of depression
when their team loses
为什么会有那么多人把生活暂且搁置，从忙碌的日子里腾出时间，疯狂地盯着电视屏幕，在客厅里踱来踱去，咬着指甲，甚至在他们支持的球队输球时陷入深深的抑郁？
and celebrate euphorically when they win
and I just thought that I was like
this is a phenomenon that's worth investigating
so I called him and pitched him the idea
and he was like immediately
saw it and we were off and running. And so we spent like a year and a half going to a bunch of
different events. We do go to mainstream American sports. We go to basketball, football, baseball.
I went to the Olympics in Paris and watched the U.S. men's basketball team. He went to a Montreal
而在球队赢球时又会兴奋若狂。我当时就觉得，这是一个值得深入调查的现象。于是我打电话给他，向他提出了这个想法。他立刻就懂了，一拍即合，我们随即展开了行动。在过去的一年半里，我们去了各种各样的活动。我们也去了主流的美国体育赛事，比如篮球、橄榄球、棒球。我去巴黎奥运会观看了美国男篮的比赛。他则去观看了蒙特利尔
Canadians hockey game with some friends in Montreal. Like we do the stuff that matters most to
Americans, but we also went to some really fun stuff that we had never heard of before. Joe went to
the indigenous stickball championships in Philadelphia, Mississippi, which is a sport that native trials.
have used to like settle disputes for like hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of years.
It's sort of like field hockey or lacrosse, but it's like played by like dozens and dozens
of people at the same time. It's sort of like lacrosse plus rugby plus like a fist fight.
And it's, you know, it's in the middle of Mississippi in the summer and it's 140 degrees with 140% humidity.
Like we went to places where there are games that matter and we tried to like figure out what
加拿大人队的冰球比赛，和蒙特利尔的朋友们一起。我们体验了对美国人来说最重要的那些体育项目，但也去了一些我们以前闻所未闻的、非常有趣的活动。乔去了密西西比州费城观看原住民棍网球锦标赛，这是当地原住民部落用来解决争端长达几百年的运动。它有点像草地曲棍球或长曲棍球，但有多达几十人同时在场上比赛。它有点像是长曲棍球加上橄榄球，再加上一场群架。而且你知道的，那是夏天密西西比州的中心地带，气温高达140华氏度，湿度高达140%。我们去了那些有着重要比赛的地方，并试图弄清楚
it was about that unites all of them and the fans who love them. But you also went to like a
Taylor Swift concert, which is another kind of fandom. Yeah. So we didn't want it to just be about
sports. So one of the things that we did was there were two really fun things that were non-sports
related. One of them was I had the idea that we should each send the other one to something that
the other one hated. Okay. It was like, I know you hate this now, but go see if you can figure out
why people like it. So I sent Joe to play pickleball.
in a pickleball tournament because he's a tennis player.
Me too.
究竟是什么将所有这些活动以及热爱它们的粉丝紧密联系在一起。不过，你还去了一场泰勒·斯威夫特的演唱会，这也是另一种粉丝文化。是的。所以我们不想让这本书只局限于体育。我们做的一件事是，安排了两个与体育无关的极其有趣的环节。其中一个是我的主意：我们互相把对方送到一样对方非常讨厌的事物中去。好吧。当时的想法是：我知道你现在讨厌这个，但去看看能不能弄明白为什么别人会喜欢它。所以我打发乔去打匹克球
There you go.
I know.
He's like pickleball's taking over and I hate it.
I hate the sound.
I hate the kitchen.
I hate that it's named after the guy's dog.
He just hates everything about it.
But he sent me to WrestleMania because I don't care at all about wrestling.
参加一场匹克球锦标赛，因为他是个网球运动员。我也是。
I don't like combat sports.
I think they're ridiculous.
And so I was like, all right, fine.
I'll go to WrestleMania.
And then my agent called me and was like, hey,
I'm taking a bunch of people to a dead-in-company show in Vegas for my birthday.
do you want to go?
And I was like, I can't.
这就对了。我懂。他觉得匹克球正在席卷一切，而他恨透了。他讨厌那个击球声，讨厌厨房区，讨厌它是以某个人的狗的名字命名的。他对这东西可以说是深恶痛绝。但他也把我派去了摔跤狂热大赛（WrestleMania），因为我对摔跤完全不感兴趣。
I'm going to WrestleMania.
And he was like, well,
WrestleMania is also in Vegas
and it's the same weekend.
And I was like, crap.
And I was like, I realized in that moment,
like, I should do both things.
Like, it's funnier to do both things.
我并不喜欢格斗运动，我觉得它们荒谬可笑。所以我当时想：好吧，行吧，我去摔跤狂热大赛。然后我的经纪人打电话给我说：‘嘿，我生日那天要带一堆人去拉斯维加斯看死忠与伙伴乐队（Dead & Company）的演出，你想去吗？’我当时就说：‘我不能去。’
So I embark on what I refer to in the book
as the world's weirdest biathlon,
where on Saturday night
I go to a dead-in-company show
and Sunday night to go to WrestleMania.
But then, you know, we were writing this book in 24, 25,
and like, it was impossible to write a book
about fandom without including Taylor Swift.
‘我要去摔跤狂热大赛。’结果他说：‘噢，摔跤狂热大赛也正好在拉斯维加斯，而且是同一个周末。’我当时心里一沉。那一刻我突然意识到：这两件事我都该去。两样都去会更有趣。
My wife and I took our daughter and some of her friends to the Arest Store.
We did the same.
Did you?
Yeah, both of us, yeah.
At SoFi?
I was in New Orleans.
Okay.
I was in Vancouver.
于是我开启了我在书中称为‘世界上最奇特的两项全能’的旅程：周六晚上我去看了死忠与伙伴乐队的演出，周日晚上则去看摔跤狂热大赛。不过话说回来，我们在24、25年写这本书的时候，如果要写一本关于粉丝文化的书却不提泰勒·斯威夫特，那是绝对不可能的。
I was at her last show.
Yeah.
My wife and my daughter were also at her second to last show.
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
But my wife and her friend also went from her friend from college and their daughters came.
And my wife's best friend made one of those photo books about it.
And the title of the book is better than our weddings.
我和我妻子带着女儿以及她的一些朋友去看了时代巡回演唱会（The Eras Tour）。我们也去了。是吗？对，我们都去了。在SoFi体育场？我在新奥尔良。好吧。我在温哥华。
because they both agreed that evening was better than each of their ways.
They were like, it was more joyous.
I was happier.
Yeah, it was more important in my life.
Like, yeah.
And Joe had taken his daughter to a Taylor Swift concert in North Carolina.
And so we were like, well, we have to write about Taylor Swift,
but what are two, like, 50-year-old dudes going to say about it
我在她的最后一场演出。对。我妻子和女儿也观看了她的倒数第二场演出。哦，哇。是的。但不仅如此，我妻子的大学室友和她们的女儿也从外地赶来。我妻子最好的朋友甚至为此做了一本照片书。那本书的名字叫《比我们的婚礼还要棒》。
that will matter nothing, but our daughters should do this.
So I had my daughter, Ivy, who's 14.
I was like, just write a chapter about what Taylor Swift means to you.
And his daughter did the same.
And then we put them together.
And it was like, and we did not edit them.
They are unedited.
They are like, this is what she wrote.
因为她们两个一致认为，那一晚比她们各自的婚礼还要美好。她们说：‘那种快乐更纯粹，我当时更幸福。’是的，它在我的生命中具有更重要的意义。没错。而且乔也带着女儿在北卡罗来纳州观看了泰勒·斯威夫特的演唱会。所以我们就在想，既然我们必须写写泰勒·斯威夫特，那两个五十岁的老家伙能说出什么
I added a few commas.
But other than that.
And so it's just a great little snapshot in time of like what Taylor Swift means to girls at different ages in the year 2024.
So there's, we tried to cover not just sports, but all fandom.
I wrote a long section on TV fandom too and wrote about like what I've observed about why TV matters to people and what is it.
about sort of bonding with characters on long-running TV shows that makes them feel like they matter in their lives and that sort of thing.
So it's really an attempt to be comprehensive about fandom as a phenomenon.
And you have some great pictures in here, too, from different events that you guys went to.
有分量的话呢？这些对我们来说可能毫无意义，但我们的女儿们应该来写。于是我让我的女儿艾薇（14岁）写了一章，谈谈泰勒·斯威夫特对她意味着什么。乔的女儿也做了同样的事。然后我们把这些内容整合在了一起，而且我们没有对它们进行编辑，它们是未经修改的原文。这就是她们写下的真实感受。
Yeah, there's some good WrestleMania pictures.
We were very close to the ring.
And I'm still not a wrestling fan, but holy moly, those athletes are doing some crazy stuff, man.
Their bodies.
They're flying.
Like, the thing I write in the book,
is, like, wrestling might be fake, but like, the sounds their bodies make when they hit the mat are
not. Like, they are really jumping and flying and twisting, and it's really wild. I went with my friend
我只加了几个逗号，除此以外别无其他。所以，这就像是2024年不同年龄段的女孩们眼中的泰勒·斯威夫特的一个绝佳时代快照。因此，我们试图涵盖的不仅是体育，而是所有的粉丝文化。我也写了很长一部分关于电视迷文化的章节，记录了我对为什么电视对人们如此重要的观察，以及人们与长寿剧集中的角色建立情感纽带的原因是什么，正是这种纽带让他们觉得这些角色在自己的生活中同样具有重要意义。所以这确实是一次试图全面探讨粉丝文化这一现象的尝试。你们在这里面还放了一些非常棒的照片，都是你们去过的不同活动的纪实照片。
Jen Statsky, who wrote with me on Parks and Rec, in the Good Place, and then created hacks,
because she's an enormous wrestling fan. And Eleanor Shellstrop, Kristen Bell's character,
and The Good Place is a huge wrestling fan and is, like, deeply in love with Stone Cold on Steve Austin.
And that all came from Jen. That was all Jen's thing. And I asked Jen to,
come with me to like be my, you know, Sherpa, to like walk me through it. And the thing she said to me,
I was like, help me understand this. Like I don't, I can't access this. It's like not a real sport.
And she goes, no, that's the whole point. She goes, the thing that's great about wrestling is that it's
the perfect marriage of sports and theater. And when you think of it as the intersection of
是的，有一些很棒的摔跤狂热大赛照片。我们的座位离擂台非常近。虽然我依然算不上一个摔跤迷，但天哪，那些运动员们在做一些极其疯狂的举动，老兄。他们的身体在飞翔。我在书里写过的一点是：摔跤可能是假的，但他们身体砸向垫子时发出的声音绝对不是假的。他们是真的在跳跃、飞腾和扭转，这实在太疯狂了。我和我的朋友
sports and theater, you can figure out why it's so compelling. And I have to say, like,
it was the perfect thing to say to me. It was like, one, I changed. I changed. I changed. I, you know,
my frame of reference to like this isn't really a sport to like it's not supposed to be it's supposed to be a
dramatic performance done by the world's best athletes and that really helped me like get to the heart
of why people are so nutty for it you know it's funny that you mention not being a fan of something
and then like getting absorbed by it so i was in new york this year when the nicks were in the
playoffs yeah what is the thing you win when you're championship
The championship, just the NBA championship.
简·斯塔斯基（Jen Statsky）一起去的，她曾和我一起创作过《公园与游憩》、《良善之地》，后来还创作了《绝望hacks》，因为她是个狂热的摔跤迷。《良善之地》中克里斯蒂安·贝尔（Kristen Bell）饰演的角色埃莉诺·谢尔斯特罗普就是个狂热的摔跤迷，并且深深地迷恋着“冷石”史蒂夫·奥斯汀。这些灵感全来自于简，这完全是简的个人爱好。我当时邀请简和我一起去，扮演我的“夏尔巴人”向导，带我一步步领略其中的门道。她对我说的一句话是这样的：我当时对她说“帮我理解这个吧，我实在无法接受，这又不是一场真正的体育比赛”。而她回答：“不，这正是精髓所在。”她说，摔跤最棒的地方在于它是体育和戏剧的完美结合。当你把它看作是
Yes, correct.
I'm like, does it have a name like the Stanley Cup?
I don't think so.
So here's the thing.
I have never watched a basketball game on television in my life.
I've been to one Lakers game.
I took my son.
I don't particularly care for basketball.
体育与戏剧的交汇点时，你就能明白它为什么如此引人入胜了。我必须承认，这话对我来说简直是点睛之笔。首先，我的观念变了。我的参照框架变了，不再认为“这不是一场真正的比赛”，而是觉得“它本来就不是一场普通的比赛，它是一场由世界上最顶尖的运动员呈现的戏剧表演”。这真的帮我抓住了人们为之疯狂的核心原因。你知道的，很有意思的是，当你原本对某样东西毫无兴趣，却最终被它彻底吸引时——比如，今年尼克斯队打进季后赛时我在纽约。对。当你赢得那个赛事时，它的奖项叫什么？总冠军，仅仅是NBA总冠军。
My opinion is that like you could just turn it on in the last three minutes.
You don't need to watch the whole thing because it just goes back and forth the whole game.
And it's just sort of like, well, I'll just watch the end.
Sure.
So haven't ever been a fan of basketball.
I spent seven days in New York during this time.
And by that last night when they won,
I was at a neighborhood watch party on the street.
是的，没错。我当时还想：它是不是像斯坦利杯那样有个特定的名字？我想是没有的。事情是这样的：我这辈子从来没在电视上看过一场篮球比赛。我只去现场看过去过一场湖人队的比赛，那是我带我儿子去的。我对篮球其实并不是特别感兴趣。
She was outside.
At a bomb, like a bar has like a TV.
Yeah.
And I was like, oh my God, if they don't fucking win.
They deserve it.
It's been 50 years.
Like I was so hardcore.
And then they won and I was like on the street.
她在外面。在一家酒吧外面，那种有电视的酒吧。对。然后我想，天哪，如果他们不他妈的赢的话。他们就太惨了。已经50年了。我当时超级狂热。然后他们赢了，我就冲到了街上。
Euphoric.
like erupted and the cars are honking and the guy's got a giant blowup basketball that we're all like kicking down the street.
Yeah.
And I was like, oh my God.
I didn't even know.
I know.
It is deeply inside us fandom.
That's one of the things that we really learned is like you can go from I don't care about this at all to if Jalen Brunson doesn't win the MVP of the finals, I will throw myself in front of a train in like a second.
那种狂喜。人群爆发了，汽车在鸣笛，有个家伙拿了一个巨大的充气篮球，我们都在街上踢来踢去。对。然后我就想，天哪。我甚至都不知道。我懂的。这种狂热深深植根于我们体内。这是我们真正学到的事情之一，就是你可以从“我根本不在乎这个”瞬间变成“如果杰伦·布朗森（Jalen Brunson）拿不到总决赛MVP，我会在一秒钟内跳轨自杀”。
Yes.
And the most sort of interesting part of this whole experience was we talked to this professor who studies sports fandom.
His name is Daniel Wan.
He teaches at Murray State University.
And the thing he said to us that rang so true was, look, if sports were just like fun and a good way to kill a couple hours, that would be fine.
But it wouldn't explain that reaction you had.
And it wouldn't explain why a billion people in the world care about it so deeply.
And he said, in order for that to be true,
是的。整段经历中最有趣的部分是，我们采访了一位研究体育迷文化的教授。他叫丹尼尔·万（Daniel Wan）。他在莫瑞州立大学（Murray State University）任教。他对我们说的话非常切中要害，他说，看，如果体育仅仅是好玩、是消磨几个小时的好方法，那倒也罢。但这无法解释你当时那种反应。也无法解释为什么世界上有十亿人对此如此深情投入。他说，要想让这一切说得通，
it must be the case that sports fandom and fandom in general is satisfying some kind of deep emotional need.
Like an emotional need is being met by this phenomenon.
And that's why it erupts out of us the way it does.
It's because it's drilling down into our souls and meeting us at some very deep and primal place.
And that feeling that you just described, so my son is a huge sports fan but has never liked soccer.
I've tried to get him to watch with me.
He doesn't care.
he thinks it's boring.
那就必然是因为，体育迷文化乃至一般意义上的粉丝文化，正在满足某种深层的情感需求。也就是说，这种现象满足了我们的某种情感需求。这就是为什么它会以那样的方式从我们体内爆发出来。因为它触及了我们的灵魂，在某个非常深邃而原始的地方与我们相遇。你刚才描述的那种感觉——比如，我儿子是个超级体育迷，但从来不喜欢足球。我曾试图让他跟我一起看。他根本不在乎。他觉得这很无聊。
There's not enough scoring, all those things that people think.
He was out with his friends on the first night of the World Cup,
and he was like, what do you guys want to do?
And they were like, there's a watch party in Korea town
because South Korea is playing in the World Cup.
And he was like, right.
And that all of a sudden I started getting these texts that was like,
this is low-key.
进球太少了，诸如此类人们常有的看法。世界杯开赛第一晚，他和朋友们在外面，他问大家想去干嘛。他们说，韩国城有个观赛派对，因为韩国队正在踢世界杯。他说，好吧。然后突然之间，我开始收到这样的短信，说这太低调了。
Lock-in, dad, low-key.
This is the most incredible thing I've ever seen.
And it's my son and his friends and like a thousand Koreans
in at like an outdoor park in Korea Town watching the World Cup.
And when they scored a goal, he was like, I've never felt anything like this in my life.
It was like a jolt of electricity.
And that night, he's staying up until three in the morning, like learning about like all the players on the team where they play, what the European leagues are,
like learning about like the transfer system in soccer, which is incredibly complicated.
嗨起来，老爸，低调个鬼。这是我见过的最不可思议的事情。那是我儿子和他的朋友们，还有韩国城露天公园里大约上千名韩国人一起在看世界杯。当他们进球时，他说，我这辈子从来没有感受过这种感觉。就像通了一股电流。那天晚上，他一直待到凌晨三点，去了解队里的所有球员、他们在哪踢球、欧洲联赛是什么样的，还去了解足球里的转会制度，那可是相当复杂的。
And now he's just got World Cup fever.
And he's like living and dying with all these matches.
And I just think it speaks to something.
There's a lot of reasons why fandom occurs in people.
But life is a little bit lonely and sports creates communities that we can feel like we're a part of.
And like you're standing on the street in New York City suddenly feeling like nothing has ever mattered more to me in my life than this thing that I did not care about one week ago.
Exactly.
I mean, on game four, we walked to Central Park and we watched the game.
现在他彻底患上了世界杯热。他随着所有这些比赛而情绪大起大落。我只是觉得这说明了一些问题。人们成为粉丝的原因有很多。但生活有点孤独，而体育创造了社区，让我们觉得我们是其中一部分。就像你站在纽约市的街头，突然觉得生命中没有什么比这件你一周前还毫不关心的事情更重要了。完全正确。我是说，第四场比赛时，我们走到中央公园去看了比赛。
like through some trees.
They had the Central Park watch party, but it was like, it was at Walman Rink.
And so it was like kind of a closed thing.
Right.
And we're like, we're standing on some rocks.
Yeah.
And I'm like, who am I?
透过一些树木。他们举办了中央公园观赛派对，但那是在沃尔曼溜冰场（Walman Rink）。所以有点像是封闭的活动。对。然后我们就站在一些岩石上。对。我就想，我是谁？对。
I didn't even know this team existed four days ago.
Yeah.
I know.
I'll tell you when I fall apart.
It doesn't matter what sports I'm watching.
I love sports.
I quickly just glom on to whatever.
What are we watching?
四天前我甚至不知道这支球队存在。对。我懂。我告诉你我什么时候会情绪崩溃。不管我看什么体育比赛。我热爱体育。我很快就会全心投入到任何赛事中。我们在看什么？
Oh, we're watching World Cup.
Great.
Okay.
Oh, champion.
whatever. I just glom on and I love it. It's the minute that moment of either triumph or failure happens,
and you see the different emotions go across the faces of thousands of people who are sharing this moment with each other.
Yeah.
哦，我们在看世界杯。太棒了。好的。哦，冠军。好的。随便什么。我就是全身心投入而且我热爱它。就是那种胜利或失败的时刻到来时，你看到成千上万分享这一刻的人们脸上流露出各种不同的情绪。对。
I, like, cry. Every time. I cry every time. Every time. I didn't know anything about Jalen. I call him by his first name now.
And I just was like, oh, like hearing his life story, I'm just like, uh-huh. And then.
And, you know, you see his mom and I'm just like, forget it.
Like, it's amazing.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
But you're right.
That shared grief is part of it, too.
我简直要哭了。每次都哭。我每次都哭。我对杰伦一无所知。我现在都直接叫他的名字了。我当时就想，哦，听到他的人生故事，我就觉得，嗯哼。然后呢。而且，你知道，你看到他的妈妈，我就想，算了。这太棒了。对。这太棒了。但你说得对，那种共同的悲伤也是其中的一部分。
It's not just the winning.
It's failures and triumphs.
And the reason, like, New York would have gone crazy no matter what, but 53 years means that
there are whole generations of people who have never known their favorite team to be a winner
at the end of the year.
The most extreme example of this in my life is I'm a Red Sox fan.
And they went 86 years.
So 32 more years, 33 more years than the NICS did without winning.
不仅仅是赢球。还有失败与胜利。原因在于，不管怎样纽约都会陷入疯狂，但53年意味着整整好几代人从来没有经历过他们最喜欢的球队在年底赢得总冠军。我这一生中最极端的例子就是我是波士顿红袜队的球迷。他们等了86年。比尼克斯队没有夺冠的时间还要多32年、33年。
And in that intervening time, sort of like the NICS, had a bunch of near misses, like a bunch of close calls and tragic failures and embarrassing errors made it the wrong time.
And when they finally won in 2004, there was an article written, many articles written about the celebration that happened.
And there was a story that I think about all the time, which is at three in the morning, a guy had a third.
thought, which was, I need to share this with my dad. And his dad had passed away many years earlier
and had never seen them win. He lived his entire life in a world in which they had never won
the World Series. And his dad was buried at Mount Auburn Cemetery outside Boston, and he got a
bottle of champagne and a Red Sox hat. He was like, I'm going to go to my dad's grave. I'm
to leave him this bottle of champagne in this Red Sox hat and just celebrate with him. And he was
在那段漫长的时间里，有点像尼克斯队，经历了一次次与胜利擦肩而过，就像一堆惊险瞬间、悲惨的失利，以及在错误时机犯下的尴尬失误。当他们在2004年终于夺冠时，有一篇文章问世了，许多文章都在报道当时发生的庆祝活动。有一个故事我一直记忆犹新，那就是在凌晨三点，有个家伙突然有了一个想法，那就是，我需要和我爸爸分享这个。而他的父亲多年前就已经去世了，生前从未见过他们夺冠。他的一生都生活在红袜队从未赢得过世界大赛的世界里。他的父亲被埋葬在波士顿郊外的奥本山公墓（Mount Auburn Cemetery），他拿了一瓶香槟和一顶红袜队帽子。他说，我要去我爸爸的墓地。我要把这瓶香槟和这顶红袜队帽子留给他，陪他一起庆祝。当时他
walking towards the cemetery and he was thinking like, how am I going to get in? Like, it's three
in the morning.
Like, there's a gate.
It's locked.
And as he was walking, he started to see other people walking in the same direction.
He got to the cemetery.
The guy who was the night guard at the cemetery had anticipated this and had unlocked the
gate and opened it.
正朝公墓走去，心里在想：我怎么才能进去？这可是凌晨三点。有大门呢。锁着的。正走着，他开始看到其他人也朝同一个方向走去。他到了公墓。公墓的夜班守卫预料到了这一点，已经把大门解锁并打开了。
He walked to his dad's grave, put the hat in the champagne down, and saw like 11 other people
just in his line of vision speaking out loud to people in their graves.
This is making me tear up.
I know.
It's beautiful.
It's so important.
and meaningful. And if you think of sports as like a distraction, a diversion from the banality of
everyday life, that's fine. That is what they are at some level. But when you have communities
他走到父亲的墓前，放下帽子和香槟，看到视线范围内大约还有其他11个人也在对着墓碑大声说话。这让我快要流泪了。我懂。这太美妙了。这太重要、太有意义了。如果你把体育看作是一种消遣，一种逃避日常生活平淡无奇的方式，那也无妨。在某种程度上，它们确实如此。但当你拥有这些社区
that bond around these teams and the fandom is passed down from generation to generation,
and important moments and memories are made alongside those teams and alongside those moments,
then it becomes something else. Then it becomes a thing where, like, you are not thinking about
necessarily like OG and Anobie's incredible tip in in game four.
What you're thinking about is your grandmother who used to sit in her living room and watch
Nick's games and root for them and who passed away 22 years ago and how much she would
have loved this moment.
And it connects you to her and it connects you to your kids and to your friends.
围绕着这些球队凝聚在一起，粉丝文化代代相传，重要的时刻和记忆伴随着这些球队和这些时刻而创造，它就变成了别的东西。然后它变成了一件这样的事：你所想的不一定非要是OG·阿奴诺比（OG Anunoby）在第四场比赛中那记不可思议的补篮。你想到的是你的祖母，她过去常常坐在客厅里看尼克斯队的比赛并为他们加油助威，她在22年前去世了，她会多么喜爱这个时刻。它将你与她连接起来，也将你与你的孩子和朋友连接起来。
And it really is, there's a great quote from the Pope of all people, not this current Pope,
but I think it was John Paul the second.
who said about soccer, calling it football as Europeans do,
he said, of all of the unimportant things, soccer is the most important.
And that's how I think we should think of these things.
It's like, yes, of course it's not as important as like a Supreme Court decision
or a federal election or the eradication of a disease.
But it is important and it's important in a way that really does matter
而且确实如此，教皇曾说过一句名言——当然不是现任教皇，我想那是若望·保罗二世（John Paul the second）。他谈到足球时（正如欧洲人那样称其为football），他说，在所有不重要的事情中，足球是最重要的。这就是我认为我们应该如何看待这些事情的方式。就像，是的，当然它不像最高法院的裁决、联邦选举或消灭某种疾病那样重要。但它确实很重要，而且它以一种对巨大人群真正重要的方式
to an enormous number of people.
And that's why we wanted to write the book.
That's so great.
Well, I think people are going to love your book.
You know, we're so thankful for our office community and the office ladies fans and the fandom
and family that we have found with them.
And you guys, we love Mike Scher.
We know you do too.
存在着。这就是我们想要写这本书的原因。太棒了。嗯，我觉得大家会喜欢你们的书的。你知道，我们非常感激我们的办公室社区，以及办公室辣妈（Office Ladies）的粉丝们，还有我们从他们身上找到的粉丝情谊和大家庭。还有你们大家，我们爱迈克·舒尔（Mike Scher）。我知道你们也一样。
You're going to love his book.
I'm going to put a link to it in our stories.
Thank you.
I hope you like it.
Mike, thanks for joining us.
It is my absolute pleasure.
It's lovely to see you.
And your generosity and talking all things, office and all things sports and fandom.
你们会喜欢他的书的。我会在我们的动态（Stories）里放一个链接。谢谢。希望你们会喜欢。迈克，谢谢你加入我们。这是我的绝对荣幸。很高兴见到你们。感谢你们慷慨地谈论所有关于办公室、关于体育和粉丝文化的一切。
I love talking about the office.
I'll talk about it forever.
Anytime you want me to come talk about the office, I'll come back.
Okay, great.
Well, we have two more years of our contracts.
There you go.
Well, good job.
Thank you.
我喜欢谈论《办公室》。我可以永远谈论它。任何时候你们想让我来聊聊《办公室》，我都会回来。好的，太棒了。嗯，我们的合同还有两年。给你。好吧，干得好。谢谢。
All right. Thanks so much.
That was wonderful.
That was so fun.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
And our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
好的。非常感谢。太棒了。太好玩了。感谢收听《办公室辣妈》。《办公室辣妈》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·派弗（Sam Pfeiffer）。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Sholes.
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
《办公室辣妈》由比尔·肖尔斯（Bill Sholes）进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Ruppertry》。